Hallo und herzlich will.
Kommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Pritler und ich begrüße alle hier zur dreiundsechzigsten Ausgabe von UKW und es ist Freitag und das heißt Corona, Weekly mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim und es ist der fünfte.
Und es ist der fünfte März, genau zwanzig einundzwanzig und ja da sind wir wieder und versuchen für euch das Geschehen äh
einzufangen. Vielleicht an dieser Stelle mal auch für Leute, die vielleicht erst
Mit dieser Sendung oder jüngst überhaupt erst eingestiegen sind. Wir sitzen hier in letzter Zeit, glaube ich, viel, wissen auch voraus. Ist vielleicht auch mal ganz angemessen,
nochmal so ein bisschen zu erklären, wie es denn eigentlich zu diesem Podcast hier gekommen ist. Ähm ist jetzt bald
glaube ich auch ein Jahr her, ne? Also wann hatten wir denn unsere erste äh Sendung nochmal? Da musste ich gleich nochmal nachschlagen, aber das muss so Mitte äh März letzten Jahres gewesen sein. Das heißt, wir nähern uns tatsächlich.
Unserem Jubiläum an der Stelle. Wenig überraschend war das ähm.
Als der Lokdown sich näherte und wir so langsam begriffen haben, was eigentlich so äh passiert mit uns, beziehungsweise angefangen haben, das zu machen, genau, der dreizehnte äh dritte, das ist dann tatsächlich,
quasi in einer Woche und ähm ja, dann.
Haben wir uns einfach mal hingesetzt und mal überlegt so, hm, okay, alles klar, da passiert grad irgendwas, da rollt irgendwas auf uns zu. Ähm, schauen wir doch mal,
ob wir da irgendwie uns einen Reim drauf äh machen können und ja da war so ist dann irgendwie Chrona, Wickly draus entstanden.
Ja, mit meinen damals war mal rekapituliert ähm da war.
Die Sache mit dem Kreuzfahrtschiff Diamond Princess, die war ja schon im Februar und.
Jahr im März so genommen.
Diese Zeit rumkam glaube ich so langsam die Bilder aus Italien äh davon Zusammenbruch äh des des Gesundheitssystems.
Und äh ja es äh wurden erste Infektionen äh gemeldet hier und da aber eigentlich, wenn man zu dem Zeitpunkt war's halt noch im Ausland
eigentlich aber es schlug so langsam um, dass das plötzlich Korona dann auch plötzlich ein inländisches Thema wurde, so mit.
Ja, Heimkehrern und äh in ersten Clustern und so und dann ging alles ganz schnell. Dann sind wir halt in den ersten.
Ja, schnellen Lokdown gegangen, so alle waren glaube ich etwas ja überrascht
all das war komplett neu, keiner wusste so genau, was was passiert da jetzt? Fallen mir jetzt
demnächst alle tot um und dementsprechend waren halt dann auch viele Leute vorsichtig, weil keiner wusste, was kommt und äh ja, wir hatten da
dann einen Lokdown, der auch den Namen verdient, also da sind wir auf einen R-Wert
Rekord war, sieben Tage RWT von null Komma sechs neun runtergekommen tatsächlich in der in der Spitze so dass wir dann halt auch nach sechs Wochen wieder
öffnen konnten und fünf Wochen später dann,
gültig öffnen und ja haben dann bei einer Neuner und dann bei einer Dreierinzidenz eben komplett,
gelockert nach elf Wochen. Also insofern.
Ist es ganz gut gelaufen, besser wär's, wenn wir noch ein, zwei Wochen früher reingegangen wären und äh wie,
die Tschechen äh äh damals, aber äh.
Dann aus einem Jahr Rückblick wär's vielleicht nicht ganz so gut gewesen. Psychologisch, weil wie wir halt wissen ähm.
Offenbar je besser irgendwie jemand die erste Welle äh gemeistert äh hat ähm.
Umso schlimmer kam's dann später, ne? Mhm.
Aber so äh ja umso.
Schlimmer kam's dann in der zweiten Welle, wenn man das dann halt komplett unterschätzt hat und alle sagten, wieso war ja nichts irgendwie in der in der ersten äh Welle. Und äh ja.
Das Ganze läuft ja auch und es taucht immer wieder auf, also auf Englisch, No Glory in Prevention oder wissenschaftlich sich das auch das Präventionsparadox so dass natürlich in dem Moment,
wo man dann gewarnt hat,
Und da durch die Warnung die Gefahr abgewendet wurde ist dann aber derjenige, der gewarnt hat, äh dann sagen diejenigen, die so, was, was hast denn du so ein so ein Gewesen darum gemacht? War ja gar nix
und das finden wir halt halt immer noch wieder
In der Debatte bis heute dieses Präventionsparadox, wenn halt Leute sagen, ja Moment, also unser Gesundheitssystem war ja gar nicht überfordert, wir hatten ja noch
locker Platz auf den Intensivstationen. Ich weiß gar nicht, was wir hier so für eine Panik machen. Da, die hätten,
wir ja viel besser ausnutzen können wie jetzt Chuperlius in der BZ äh äh so schrieb. So, wann erfahren wir endlich die Wahrheit über die Intensivstation
Ja, gut, der Typ ist eigentlich gut. Ähm,
Ja, sage ich nicht über viele Leute, aber äh gut, nein, eigentlich ist er berufstroll, äh der
Weiß nicht, ich glaube genau weiß, was er macht und den sich die BZ halt hält äh um Klicks zu erzeugen. Also auch als Troll kann man offensichtlich Karriere machen.
Definitiv.
Ja Panikmacher, das wurde uns ja auch vorgeworfen, als wir so unsere erste Sendung rausgeworfen haben und versucht haben, so ein bisschen die Gefahr der Bedrohung irgendwie einzuordnen und äh das hat so einigen Leuten nicht
passt und ähm am Ende glaube ich lagen wir so mit unseren generellen Einschätzungen nicht komplett daneben.
Und hoffen natürlich, dass wir das auch weiter so bestand hält.
Für euch ist das also hier auf jeden Fall eine Informationssendung. Wir versuchen so nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen so ein bisschen zusammenzukehren und zusammenzurechnen, was sich uns eben so präsentiert. Wir sind da nicht äh.
Ohne viel und so sehr wir hoffen, dass uns Fehler auch mal gestattet werden, versuchen wir sie auch zu vermeiden, aber wird nicht immer funktionieren.
Oder dann zu korrigieren oder einzugestehen, wenn äh ja äh Dinge nicht ganz äh richtig waren.
Da haben wir ja im Prinzip jetzt auch schon was zu berichten. Denn derzeit
funktioniert ja deine tolle Risikotabelle, da pabel Meier DE Slash Kowit Slash Risks. Ja, die hat jetzt ein rotes Banner bekommen, was äh was ist los? Pavel, was was ist passiert.
Ja, also irgendwie begannen in den letzten zwei Wochen so langsam äh die Zahlen ähm auseinanderzulaufen, die meine Tabelle äh,
lieferte mit den Zahlen, die ich.
Mit einem anderen Verfahren auch noch rechne so und mit den offiziellen Zahlen und das äh passierte halt aber graduell und so,
ganz genau klar ist mir das noch nicht, warum jetzt mein erstes Verfahren jetzt plötzlich überhöhte Zahlen auswirft. Grundsätzlich liegt es halt daran,
dass.
Jeder tägliche Damp, jeder tägliche Zahlendampf vom RKI enthält halt nicht nur neue Fälle, sondern auch Korrekturen zu Altfällen, die so sagen in,
älteren Dampf enthalten waren. Zwischen neunzig und neunundneunzig Prozent der Daten sind identisch,
kommen, was halt ein bisschen nervt, äh wenn man halt tägliche Dampf speichern muss und eigentlich neunzig Prozent der Daten sind halt.
Überflüssig doppelt. So und deswegen habe ich versucht halt diese doppelten Daten rauszurechnen, damit ich die halt nicht speichern muss, weil,
äh das das kostet halt nur Rechenzeit und Speicherplatz und macht das Ganze sehr unhandlich. Aber.
Das Problem ist, das halt, ich weiß nicht, ob das absichtlich oder zufällig,
passiert die Damps von einem Tag zum anderen passen halt nicht zusammen, da sind halt plötzlich in einem neuen Damp.
Altfälle drin mit negativen Zahlen, also es ist halt dann eine Korrektur zu einem Altfall, da ist halt ja,
der falsch erfasst worden oder wie auch immer und dann gibt's halt negative äh Zahlen da drin. Und.
Das da kann man natürlich dann haushalten so nach dem Motto okay, da ist jetzt irgendwie in dem Landkreis, in dem Alter eine Frau an Demut dem Tag gemeldet worden, die ist aber jetzt offensichtlich gar nicht
gar keinen Fall mehr oder war gar kein Fall mehr und,
dann versucht man das natürlich den den Fall zu finden, der vorhergemeldet wurde, weil wenn ich den Fall abziehe, dann muss es den Fall ja vorher gegeben haben, aber das gelingt halt nicht in allen Fällen einen Fall zu finden
In den alten äh Daten. So äh was halt ein ein Problem ist und irgendwie es halt in den letzten, weiß ich
vermutlich so zwei Wochen dieses äh ganze dann auseinander gelaufene, deutlich mehr auseinander gelaufen, als es.
Im letzten Jahr der Fall war und deswegen habe ich die Tabelle jetzt mit dem Warenhinweis versehen und werde jetzt zeitnah äh auf das zweite Verfahren umstellen.
Und wann Christo ist wieder gefixt.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass ich äh irgendwie jetzt am Wochenende damit durchkomme, das heißt, da wird sich dann äh die Tabelle auch erstmal ändern, weil ich glaube ich nicht von Anfang an nicht
alle Features oder nicht nicht alle Spalten nach dem neuen Verfahren so berechnen kann. Aber.
Ja, das grundsätzliche Ranking und so.
Äh wird's halt auch geben plus. Dann äh also Vorteil äh wird sein, dass die Zahlen dann halt äh haargenau mit
zumindest den RKI-Fall zahlen und den RKI Sterbezahlen, die da täglich vermeldet werden übereinstimmen werden.
Du hast ja auch ein paar Gedanken gemacht, wie das so grundsätzlich sich noch so entwickeln äh kann, was nicht spitze jetzt noch was zu sagen.
Ja, wir könnten, vielleicht sollten wir jetzt erstmal zu den Zahlen kommen und dann könnten wir vielleicht später nochmal einen Blog einschieben, äh sagen nochmal, so eine Art Technik
Block für all diejenigen, äh die vielleicht auch mithelfen äh wollen oder ja äh vielleicht mit Rat und Tat äh zur Seite stiegen wollen, wollte ich dann mal.
Nur kämpfen.
Situation und die Ideen einfach präsentieren und.
Okay, ab am Ende dann oder was? Okay.
Ja, dann kommen wir doch mal so zu den äh Zahlen, wie sie sich jetzt so darstellen. Also trotz dieser Probleme der Tabelle sind wir noch in der Lage, die Zahlen zu interpretieren, ne? Das nochmal äh.
Wie er ja äh.
Vorne weg, aber ich glaube, wir hatten letzte Woche doch eine kleine Abweichung in unserer Aussage mit dem Ehrwert, ne?
Der, der, den wir letzte Woche vermeldet hatten, war äh äh schon ein bisschen wir hatten, glaube ich, letzte Woche eins Komma eins drei vermeldet, glaube ich.
Das stand zumindest in der Tabelle.
Ja und äh tatsächlich waren's nur eins Komma null neun
So, also null Komma null vier Abweichung, das ist jetzt zwar nicht die Welt, aber beim RWT äh machen halt auch
kleine Abweichungen dann ein riesen Unterschied für wie das dann in der Zukunft weitergeht und
Wir wollten das halt er hier dann auch nochmal richtig stellen.
Also diese Feststellung, was was ist wirklich schwierig, ne? Also ich habe auch nochmal so in die Corona Warn App äh reingeschaut bei mir ähm und heute
Also es wird ja jetzt mittlerweile, wenn ja auch ein paar Daten angezeigt
Ne, die sollen in Maße, wie mir das irgendwie lieb wäre, aber zumindest ist es schon mal da. Und da wird dann so eine sieben Tage Insedenz äh geliefert von.
Angeblich fünfundsechzig Komma vier, ja. Äh daneben ist so ein kleiner Pfeil, der sagt, steigt.
Und daneben ist so ein kleines Panel, da steht äh sieben Tage R wert.
Der wird mit null Komma neun neun angegeben.
Wo ich mich halt frage so, hm, wenn die Institz steigt, hm, wie kann dann der Ehrwert unter eins sein.
Das ist halt äh ja ich meine erstmal.
Inzidenzberechnung von fünfundsechzig Komma vier ist.
Ist wieder auch nicht die Zahl der Fälle, die in den letzten sieben Tagen vermeldet wurden, sondern da fehlen äh halt die Fälle, die in den letzten sieben Tagen gemeldet wurden
aber wo sich die Leute halt vor acht Tagen,
oder länger äh beim Gesundheitsamt gemeldet haben, ne. So
nimmt man die offiziellen täglich gemeldeten Zahlen der letzten sieben Tage und teilt die durch achthundertdreißig, das ist nämlich so die die Formel wiegen dreiundachtzig Millionen, also.
Woche Fälle,
in den letzten sieben Tagen zusammenzählen und durch achthundertdreißig teilen und dann habt ihr die sieben Tage Instit und die liegt bei neunundsechzig Komma sieben,
ja, nicht bei fünfundsechzig Komma vier, also fünfundsechzig null Komma vier, kommt halt nur raus, wenn man halt.
Fälle der letzten sieben Tage einfach wegwirft. So, also in den letzten sieben Tagen gemeldete Fälle einfach wegwirft und.
Da das halt ständig passiert ist auch die vom RKI vermeldete sieben Tage Institut zu niedrig.
So und mit dem RWT wird's halt jetzt nochmal komplizierter ähm weil,
Beim RWT hängt es halt.
Auch von sogar vom Interpulationsverfahren, das war beim sieben Tage R-Wert weniger macht sowieso keinen Sinn, äh, zu berechnen, aber je nachdem wann ich die sieben Tage zusammenfasse, also wenn ich wenn ich sagen den R Wert, für den,
Für alle sieben Tage berechne und dann den Durchschnittswert kommt was anderes dabei raus als wenn
ich an die Werte der letzten sieben Tage nehme und die Werte der sieben Tage davor und dann daraus äh haltenden RWT,
bilde. Und es gibt noch ein, zwei andere äh Möglichkeiten, da einen sieben Tage RWT zu bilden und
die liefern, wenn so lange sich nichts ändert, liefern die die gleichen Werte, aber manche der Interpulationsverfahren steigen halt schneller oder fallen halt früher am, egal. Ich finde,
das Verfahren kann man auch sagen, um den RWR zu berechnen und einen relativ robusten Ehrwert zu berechnen, kann auch jeder selber machen. Ist einfach.
Fälle der letzten sieben Tage zusammenzählen, die Fälle der sieben Tage davor zusammenzählen
Das Ganze durcheinander teilen, dann kriege ich halt schon mal die Prozentzahl, nämlich in dem Fall jetzt äh aktuell fünf Komma zwei Prozent mehr Fälle,
gegenüber der Vorwoche,
Das heißt, ich habe da eine eins Komma null fünf zwei kommt halt in dem Fall dabei raus und die nehme ich dann noch hoch, vier Siebte
dann komme ich auf dem RWT hoch vier siebte einfach wegen dem seriellen Intervall von vier Tagen
weil ich aber die Daten von einer Woche betrachte, den Unterschied von einer Woche und der Ehrwert basiert halt auf vier Tagen, deswegen muss ich das noch hoch vier Siebte nehmen und dann.
Kriege ich einen aktuellen R-Wert und dann werden wir schon, der ist halt ganz leicht gesunken
jetzt und befindet sich bei eins Komma null drei. Das ist sozusagen
der logische Ehrwert, äh so würde ich das mal nennen, der logische sieben Tage RWT, der auch größer als ist, wenn die Zahlen gestiegen sind und kleiner eins ist, wenn die Zahlen gefallen sind.
Der logische Er.
Der RKI Wert ist es deswegen nicht, weil dieser einmal Intapulation, aber vor allem, weil der eben auf diesem No-Cast
basiert und dieses Nowcast wiederum versucht zeitlich den Wert ein bisschen
ja näher an die Gegenwart ranzurücken, weil ja die Zahlen, die wir jetzt.
Sagen heute haben tatsächlich den Infektionsaktivitäten von vor zehn Tagen entsprechen
und wir haben aber natürlich in den letzten zehn Tagen oder das LKI hat in den letzten zehn Tagen ja auch neue Zahlen gekriegt, das heißt viele Zahlen, also ein Großteil kommt nach ein.
Tag, nach zwei Tagen und dann ja, dauert so zehn, vierzehn Tage bis halt
alle Zahlen von Infektionen eingetroffen sind und das RKI versucht halt jetzt auf Basis der Zahlen, die jetzt so in den letzten drei Tagen,
gemeldet worden, zu berechnen, wie viel denn wahrscheinlich noch kommen werden.
Und berechnet auf dieser Basis dann äh den den R Wert. Und
Das ist jetzt ich sag mal grundsätzlich nicht nicht verkehrtes zu tun, weil man da potentiell auch einen R-Wert.
Bekommt der zeitlich näher an den tatsächlichen Infektionsgeschehen liegt. Problem ist nur, äh es versteht kein Mensch und äh wenn man dann das rückwirkend betrachtet.
Ändert sich dann auch der Wert für die Vergangenheit, also wenn ich dann in die RKI-Berichte reingucke, dann entspricht der Ehrwert von,
vier vor vier Wochen, den sie jetzt ausweisen, nicht dem RWT, den sie vor vier Wochen ausgewiesen haben.
Ja, weil er sich die ganze Zeit anpasst.
Weil er sich halt anpasst und wenn man das beobachtet, hat man festgestellt, dass
natürlich weil's 'ne Vorhersage ist sozusagen das dann mal der mit Hilfe von Nowcast berechnete Erwert zu tief war und mal der zu hoch war aber
meistens war er zu niedrig. So, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, ja?
Du meinst das RKI lebt in so einer fortfährenden Optimismusblase.
Ähm teilweise ja, also jedenfalls, was den, was den RWT äh angeht, wobei.
Dass auch Zufall sein kann, dass das so ist oder das kann halt irgendwie einen Beiß in dem verwendeten Nowcast äh Verfahren,
sein, der irgendwie dem inne wohnt, der dazu führt. Sollte es eigentlich nicht, aber.
Also so genau habe ich es dann jetzt nicht erforscht ähm.
Demnächst mal äh auch wieder versuchen, meinen eigenen Now-Cars zu machen, aber ähm gibt erstmal genug anderes zu tun.
Wollte ich auch gerade sagen, die Baustellen sind jetzt gerade schon weit ausgestreckt.
Genau. Ja. Also werfen wir da jetzt mal einen Blick auf die äh irgendeinen.
Wollte ich auch gerade vorschlagen, was was sagt uns denn jetzt sozusagen das aktuelle Zahlenmaterial über die Situation in Deutschland.
Ja, also bis vor drei Wochen, ja, zweieinhalb bis drei Wochen äh.
Ist die sieben Tage Instit in Deutschland gefallen seit zweieinhalb bis drei Wochen steigt sie wieder,
zwar leicht, also
ist jetzt kein, kein spektakulär Steiler äh Anstieg, aber so pro Woche ja, fünf bis zehn Prozent ungefähr, äh die das Ganze angestiegen ist.
Wenn ich mir den Anstieg anschaue, die mir da jetzt sehen in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen und das mal einfach so von der Kurve her gegen das Geschehen vor der zweiten Welle halte, so, dann ist das schon ein schärferer Anstieg, als wir im letzten September.
Gesehen haben. Und das natürlich auch noch auf einem viel höheren Niveau, ne.
Also genau, wir sind wir sind.
Immer noch was die Rhein-Fallzahlen angeht, sind wir nie unter den Höhepunkt der ersten Welle gekommen,
wo wir ja äh so eine Institanz von fünfzig hatten auf dem Höhepunkt und bundesweit sind wir ja nicht äh unter die fünfzig gekommen.
Also man könnte sagen, dass wir da die erste Welle ja wahrscheinlich etwas die erste Welle wurde.
Weniger gut gemessen als es vielleicht angemessen gewesen wäre, einfach mangelhafter Test. Man kann halt, wenn man gerade so die positiven Rate vergleicht.
Schon sagen, dass die erste Welle vermutlich höher war und wenn wir jetzt mal wirklich auf der positiven Rate äh angehen, sind wir.
Na ja, da wo wir so ähm im Prinzip vor genau einem Jahr waren, ne? Da ist sozusagen die positiven Rate. Also wir sind jetzt eigentlich genau da, wo wir so zum Beginn der ersten Welle äh waren und.
Zum Höhepunkt der.
Von der positiven Rate her waren wir so eher so am Anfang. Ähm aber steigt derzeit auch wieder und das ist alles nicht gut.
Ja, äh gut, wenn du, du müsstest eher vielleicht aber zur Normierung die Zahl der Toten äh vergleichen und da liegen wir halt geringfügig.
Das ist richtig, genau.
Das natürlich extrem von den Testzahlen also die Testzahlen haben sich halt viel stärker
verändert und äh insofern äh ja äh ist die positiven Quote ein zusätzlicher Indikator, um um das zu äh Normen
aber der Beste ist halt.
Stimmt, wenn man die Todesrate vergleicht, also jetzt sterben derzeit noch mehr Leute als zum höchsten Punkt der ersten Welle gestorben sind. Es ist davon auszugehen, dass wir jetzt noch eine Woche fallende Sterbezahlen haben werden,
danach ist es glaube ich wieder offen, ne?
Ja gut es könnte sein.
Nicht so weit runterkommen wie in der ersten Welle.
Es könnte sein, äh jetzt äh dass irgendwie doch die Impfungen der alten langsam anfangen, zumindest.
Da einen Einfluss zu haben. Also da geht uns dann jetzt durch die Impfungen jetzt auch so ein bisschen die Normierungsmöglichkeit.
Äh vergessen, genau, wie wir natürlich auch generell die Impfung in irgendeiner Form auch schon einen Einfluss haben, bloß eben kein
nennenswerten. Trotzdem steigen die Fälle, die Impfung alleine bringt's derzeit halt einfach noch nicht, es gibt einfach noch genug Leute, die sich nie infiziert haben.
Ja
Und nicht geimpft sind.
Genau, also ähm
Genau, um mal konkret äh vielleicht jetzt nochmal, also die Institenz hatten wir, liegt jetzt äh neunundsechzig Komma sieben, also praktisch siebzig und das entspricht halt
eben ja siebenundfünfzigtausendachthundertachtunddreißig Fällen in den letzten sieben Tagen, die gemeldet wurden
und ja fünf Prozent fünf Komma zwei Prozent mehr als in der Woche davor und
bei den Toten, um das auch nochmal gesagt zu haben, waren's ja eintausendneunhundertfünfundachtzig in den letzten sieben Tagen, das sind entspricht zweihundertvierundachtzig pro Tag
das sind vierzehn Prozent weniger gegenüber der Vorwoche.
Gewesen, also da fallen äh die Zahlen derzeit noch ganz gut und ja, was jetzt die Tests angeht,
da hatten wir ja schon erwähnt, die Testzahlen sind jetzt leicht,
angestiegen in der KW acht, da ist die KW acht ging bis zum achtundzwanzigsten zwoten. Ähm.
Und äh da sind die um vier Komma zwei Prozent angestiegen gegenüber der Woche davor. Also wenn sie jetzt statt bei eins Komma null acht Millionen bei eins Komma eins drei Millionen Tests,
und ja die Zahl der positiven Tests äh in der Woche ist halt auch um vier Komma sieben sieben Prozent gestiegen,
Also passt halt so ein bisschen zur.
Aktuellen Institutionrate äh äh also Institanzanstieg klar, weil die Institz ist halt die Zahl der positiven Tests,
so
Dazu kommen und äh dementsprechend äh dann äh das Verhältnis daraus, also die positiven Quote ist jetzt eben um null Komma.
Sechs eins Prozent angestiegen, also ganz geringfügig und die Kids wieder bei sechs Komma eins Prozent.
Ja, aber sie steigt jetzt überhaupt das erste Mal wieder, nachdem sie einfach jetzt über eine sehr, sehr, sehr langen Zeitraum gefallen ist. So, also seit ähm ja, Anfang des Jahres kann man sagen.
Das heißt also auf jeden Fall die Trend
Wende ist real und basiert jetzt nicht auf irgendwelchen jetzt mehr oder weniger Tests oder sonstigen Dingen, sondern ja äh sagen
Testquote bestätigt eben auch gerade einen.
'n Anstieg in der Größenordnung von fünf Prozent pro Woche der Real passiert.
Ja, was machen wir da draus? Also was was heißt das jetzt sozusagen? Dritte Welle, ja nein, äh ist sie das schon oder ist das nur so ein Ausmiandal und haben wir noch eine Chance in irgendeiner Form wieder nach unten abzubiegen.
Schwierig zu sagen, ne?
Ich meine, es ist immer so, sind, sind dann eben verschiedene Faktoren, die an dem
Wert zuppeln, also die den entweder nach oben oder nach nach unten ziehen und,
um jetzt die weitere Entwicklung vorhersagen zu können, reichen die Zahlen alleine nicht aus, sondern man muss eigentlich vorhersagen, wie sich die Leute jetzt verhalten.
Werden in nächster Zeit oder äh gut man kann auch gucken, wie sie sich denn in den letzten vierzehn Tagen verhalten haben und.
Je mehr Kontakte, umso mehr Infektionen und ich sehe nicht, dass jetzt in den nächsten Wochen.
Sich die Kontakte äh weiter reduzieren würden angesichts der Lockerung, sondern ich hab,
Gefühl die gehen definitiv nach oben. Ich hab jetzt nun mir noch nicht die Mobilitätsdaten die aktuellen angesehen aber
genügte teilweise auch ein Blick aus dem Fenster um zu sehen, äh was teilweise
draußen los ist, Maskendisziplin hat auch leicht abgenommen, habe ich, habe ich das Gefühl vor allem so an Haltestellen
und so oder wo wo halt Leute im im Freien aufeinander treffen sieht man dann doch halt ja.
Wieder mehr ohne Maske und das wird den RWT äh sicherlich nach oben treiben, aber vor allem,
worauf wir halt wenig Einfluss haben, äh ist halt die Zahl der Mutanten, die jetzt ansteigt und,
erwartungsgemäß, wenn man prognostiziert prognostiziert haben, haben wir jetzt nach den letzten Erhebungen die fünfzig Prozent überschritten, also,
Ähm so die Hälfte der neuen Fälle, die wir sehen äh ist äh mit B eins eins sieben oder irgendeiner anderen,
gefährlichen Mutante und das wird halt weiter zunehmen eigentlich
ist davon auszugehen, dass diese neuen Mutanten äh die Alten komplett verdrängen werden,
ähm es wird zwar dauern, es geht, sie halten sich dann eventuell noch lange mit kleinen Prozentzahlen und so, aber äh ja und,
da wir wissen, dass halt diese neuen Mutanten, die B eins eins sieben deutlich ansteckender sind, steigt halt dann auch mit der Verbreitung dieser neuen Mutanten, einfach der RW, wenn man nichts anderes,
dagegen tut.
Ich habe mir mal die Mobilitätsdaten äh angeschaut.
Oh, also ich sehe jetzt hier die von Apple, es gibt ja noch welche von Google, aber ich glaube, die sind weitgehend identisch. Ähm tja, also ÖPNV liegt zwei Prozent unter dem Schnitt.
Gewöhnlich.
Dem Jahr, also dem.
Dem üblichen Jahresschnitt, den man so vor der.
Nicht Pandimi-Schnitt. Mhm.
Den nicht, habe einen Palemie-Schnitt genau. Äh Geaktivität liegt fünf Prozent drunter, Fahraktivität liegt elf Prozent drunter oder mal anders ausgedrückt,
Das nähert sich schon wieder dem normal an. Interessant auch, dass ähm die Zeitskala ist hier nicht besonders.
Gut, aber es gab vor ein paar Tagen beim Gehen einen extremen Ausriss nach oben, der auch schon so über die äh äh null Prozentmarke rübergeht. Ich vermute mal, da sehen wir quasi das Wetter.
Da war's dann warm äh in weiten Teilen Deutschlands, hier in Berlin waren's halt was weiß ich, glaube achtzehn Grad äh im Maximum, Sonnenschein, Pipapo. Man sieht halt sofort, es zieht die Leute äh raus.
Der berühmte Berliner Februarsommer. Ähm.
Genau.
Immer kurz vor dem März-Winter äh.
Also anders ausgedrückt in den Mobilitätsdaten ist keinerlei Lokdown-Effekt mehr zu sehen.
Um's mal sozusagen. Also man kann jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob's äh elf Prozent weniger Fahraktivität und zwei Prozent weniger ÖPNV, Aktivität irgendwie nennenswert ist, aber,
das das war mal ganz anders, ja? Also wir waren im äh ersten Lokdown, ging das innerhalb kürzester Zeit auf minus sechzig Prozent runter. Und.
NV sogar auf minus siebzig Prozent. Davon sind wir sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr weit äh entfernt. Wir hatten im Dezember so um Weihnachten rum äh vergleichbare Zahlen,
was so fahren und Gen betrifft so halt dieser Weihnachtseffekt, das hat sich dann aber im Januar relativ schnell erholt und seitdem eben konsequent wieder nach oben gegangen.
Der Saisonale Effekt da ist er.
Ja, ja.
Winter und Temperatur, weil äh das halt natürlich auch, ich nenne es mal positiv die Hoffnung vieler ist, dass wir jetzt
äh eigentlich keine Maßnahmen brauchen, weil ja Corona so eine saisonale Infektion ist und das geht im Sommer,
einfach weg, sobald's jetzt warm wird, ähm
ja äh brauchen wir uns eigentlich keine Sorgen mehr zu machen und äh ob wir jetzt Loktown machen oder nicht, das spielt jetzt angeblich keine Rolle, weil uns das Wetter halt
komplett rausreißen wird und äh sowieso wir keinen Einfluss äh darauf haben, ob Blockdown oder nicht.
Dazu zwei äh Dinge, also die Politik hat nur einen bedingten Einfluss darauf,
wie sich die Leute
Verhalten, das kann man halt an Tschechien ganz gut äh sehen. Also es wo wir jetzt irgendwie Lockdown ist, heißt das nicht, dass die Leute sich auch alle dran halten. Das sind sagen zwei Dinge, aber es beeinflusst es. Äh.
Natürlich und äh zur Saisonalität also ja,
man kann davon ausgehen, dass es eine Saisonalität bei der Übertragung auch von jetzt Kovit oder Saaskov zwei gibt, das heißt der RWT im Sommer,
wenn man nichts tut äh ist halt niedriger als der R-Wert im Winter, wenn man nichts tut.
Wenn man dasselbe tut im Winter wie im Sommer, dann äh gibt's eben auch entsprechend prozentuale Veränderungen und die Frage ist jetzt, wie groß äh ist der,
Und die Studienlage dazu ist ähm,
kompliziert. Also in den Studien, es war so vier oder fünf, die ich mir da äh durchgesehen habe.
Wird von ganz verschiedenen Ergebnissen für verschiedene Länder berichtet. Das heißt mal findet sich.
Starke Wetterabhängigkeit oder Klima oder Breitengradabhängigkeit mal nicht mal findet sich das mit steigender Temperatur
Zahlen steigen und nicht abnehmen aufgrund von auf soziokulturellen Faktoren.
Also wenn die Leute halt mehr rausgehen, dann.
Kompensiert, äh dass das Ganze. Man geht davon aus, dass vor allem Sonnenscheindauer, also durch die UV-Strahlung, dass das mit.
Die stärkste Korrelation hat zu Rückgang, wie gesagt, bei Temperaturen
Und so gibt's da widersprüchliche Ergebnisse, teilweise kommt man nur Korrelation mit Tiefsttemperaturen, aber nicht mit Höchsttemperaturen feststellen, was auch keinen Sinn macht. Luftfeuchtigkeit für sich genommen,
spielt auch nicht so die Rolle, weil äh da hat man festgestellt, dass äh die entsprechend auch mit der Lufttemperatur halt, also die,
äh sich sich verändert und äh es da halt große Koalition zwischen Luftfeuchtigkeit und Temperatur gibt,
wie auch immer eine recht gute Studie ging.
Von dann einem Unterschied zwischen Sommer und Winter von siebzehn Prozent.
Aus und die.
Studien mit den höchsten Werten gingen von dreißig Prozent aus, was sich aber ja für definitiv zu hoch halte, aber man kann sagen, irgendwo
sagen die Saisonalität wenn man zwischen.
Fünfzehn und dreißig Prozent irgendwo dürfte das Ganze liegen so,
Wenn ich jetzt eine Motivation habe, die vierzig Prozent ansteckender ist, dann heißt das.
Dass wenn man B eins eins sieben im Sommer.
Immer noch ansteckender ist als Corona Classic im Winter, ja? Und.
Diese Größenordnung immer fünfzehn bis dreißig Prozent entspricht.
Auch den gemessenen Wirkungen von Maßnahmen, also nicht Pharmazeutischen Interventionen äh NPIs oder.
Maßnahmen, die wir die dann, wenn viele davon zusammenkommen, man halt als Lokdown bezeichnet und.
Es gibt da eine Reihe von Starken Maßnahmen, die auch in der Größenordnung zwischen fünfzehn und dreißig Prozent liegen,
dazu gehört das Verbot von Großveranstaltungen liegt in der Größenordnung des Schließen von Schulen und Kitas.
In der Größenordnung des Schließen äh des Einzelhandels.
Liegt in der Größenordnung ähm ja.
Mit anderen Worten. Ja, es gibt einen Einfluss, aber nein
erreicht alleine nicht ansatzweise aus, um in irgendeiner Form eine Trendwende zu erzielen, schon gar nicht mit der neuen Mutation, die jetzt vorherrscht
und äh perspektivisch auch nicht mit anderen Mutationen und das ist halt etwas, was man eigentlich rausrechnen muss oder.
Also man kann sagen über den Daumen gepeilt. Im Sommer kommt man mit einer großen Maßnahme weniger aus als im Winter. So.
Aber man braucht eh schon mal mehrere.
Aber äh so eben ja jetzt.
Durch halt die die neuen Varianten ja. Meine auch auch mit der alten Variante kann man nicht komplett aufmachen, das haben halt die Tschechen erlebt, dass was passiert, wenn man.
Wirklich komplett.
Alles unterlässt, weil die Tschechen hatten dann im Sommer alles auf. Und da gab's genau null Einschränkungen äh und,
Das hat dann äh eben die Institutionen dort,
innerhalb von dann zwei Monaten auf Werte über tausend anwachsen lassen und.
Aber die Herden, Immunität, Pavel.
Die wird uns retten.
Also.
Ob wir Herdenimunität erreichen jemals ist fragwürdig.
Insbesondere bei den aktuellen Virusvarianten, bei den Neuen bräuchten wir so achtzig bis fünfundachtzig Prozent. Ähm Immunität.
Gut, eventuell könnten wir die auch dann durch,
Durch Infektion der Impfunwilligen erreichen, die sich halt dann vollziehen wird und im Moment muss man sagen hat das Virus ja auch fast.
Allen Ländern ähm noch einen deutlichen Vorsprung vor der Impfung.
So, weil sagen wir mal, gut, so auf lange Sicht kann man halt wählen zwischen Impfung und Infektion. So eins von beiden kann man sich dann.
Aussuchen an irgendeinem Punkt. Und im Moment liegt halt noch die äh Infektion deutlich vorne, weil ähm.
Ja äh.
Wir haben, wenn wir zu den Impfungen kommen, ah, da haben wir auch auch schöne neue Zahlen, aber liegen wir so größenordnungsmäßig, je nachdem, was man zählt bei fünf bis zehn.
Prozent ähm äh Größenordnungsmäßig ähm.
Und ja bei der durch Infektion der Bevölkerung wahrscheinlich irgendwo bei zehn bis zwanzig Prozent.
Das hilft uns nicht wirklich weiter.
Ähm nee und in Tschechien ist es, habe ich auch oft oft schon gesagt, in Tschechien ist es so, dass der Virus äh im Moment mehr Leute erreicht, jeden Tag als die Impfung.
Und ja bei uns sieht es da zum Glück äh.
Doch ganz ganz anders aus, also bei uns werden pro Tag
jetzt ja vierzig Mal so viele Leute ungefähr geimpft, wie sich infizieren, das heißt, wir sollten eigentlich das Virus bald aufgeholt haben,
wenn wir jetzt nicht äh zu heftig äh in die äh dritte Welle gehen.
Dann lassen sie nochmal kurz den Blick auf ähm Berlin werfen.
Da haben wir ja den genaueren Blick insbesondere den Blick auf die Verteilung, auf die äh einzelnen Altersgehorten, wie es so schön heißt.
Ja. Also in Berlin, wenn man sehen die Zahlen.
Ähnlich aus wie im Bund. Da gibt's halt keine spektakulären Abweichungen, aber.
Okay, also bei den Altersgruppen in Berlin haben wir jetzt,
vor allem Anstiege gerade wieder bei den jüngeren Leuten, also in Altersgruppe fünf.
Bis vierzehn ist es halt deutlich hochgegangen, aber auch bei fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig äh sehen wir halt einen äh ja deutlichen Anstieg,
die Institutionen bei den über achtzigjährigen sind noch stabil.
Steigen jetzt auch ganz leicht in den in den letzten Tagen ja also.
Fängt jetzt bei den jüngeren Leuten äh gerade äh wieder an äh vor allem nach oben zu gehen.
Und vor allem die Achtziger, die gehen deutlich nach unten.
Ja und die sind die Achtziger äh sind weiter nach unten gegangen, das ist auf jeden Fall äh positiv. Die sind jetzt sagen die Inzidenzen bei den Achtzigern äh sind jetzt.
Erstmals seit einer, seit einer Woche ungefähr liegt die unter den fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen. Das hat,
seit vier Monaten nicht mehr gegeben.
Auch knapp unter den fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzigjährigen. Also sogar das ist schon passiert und sieht auch so aus, als ob äh demnächst auch die Gruppe von fünf bis vierzehn da äh auch davor liegt. Also.
Da zeigt sich offensichtlich wirklich schon eine äh Auswirkung der Impfung.
Ja und nur um dazu jetzt passend, okay mal, wie viel sind, wo stehen wir denn jetzt in Berlin mit den Impfungen und in Berlin haben jetzt fünf Komma fünf vier.
Prozent.
Der Berliner haben jetzt die erste Dosis erhalten und drei Komma drei vier Prozent haben jetzt die zweite Dosis äh enthalten und insgesamt wurden halt.
Dreihundertvierunddreißigtausend Impfdosen verabreicht bisher.
Ja meiste mit Bayerntech und bei Astra Sinnika hat in Berlin noch niemand die zweite Dosis bekommen bisher.
Aber ja generell ist
zu erwarten wohl, dass das Impftempo im März und dann vor allem im April äh irgendwann doch nochmal deutlicher anziehen wird. Also es zieht jetzt auch gerade wieder etwas mehr an
nachdem das so den ganzen Januar eigentlich bis Mitte Februar.
Hat sich da nichts getan. Also im Grunde genommen von Mitte Januar bis Mitte Februar gab es keinen Anstieg äh bei der Zahl der täglichen Impfungen in in Berlin, aber jetzt seit.
Drei Wochen äh ja steigt halt auch wieder die Zahl. Natürlich längst nicht genug, aber gut, das war ja von Anfang an klar, dass halt.
Vor Ende März ähnlich viel passieren wird bei den.
Genau, aber es ist generell, also wenn man jetzt auf ganz Deutschland blicken, sieht man, dass jetzt die Zahl der Impfungen doch ansteigt.
Also es ist jetzt wirklich im letzten Monat ist äh das kontinuierlich angewachsen.
Laut Impf der Sport hatten wir gestern zweihundertfünfundzwanzigtausend Impfungen, so viel gab's glaube ich an einem Tag noch nie. Und das ist schon mal ganz gut, dass jetzt hier sich also wirklich zeigt, dass sich was äh.
Bewegt.
Nö, das ist definitiv äh erfreulich, ja.
Der Mittwoch war sogar noch ein bisschen besser als der Donnerstag, aber es geht auf jeden Fall nach oben. Ganz klar.
Leider natürlich alles kein Vergleich mit ähm den Ländern, wo's.
Dann doch deutlich schneller vorangeht. Also UK kommt ja ganz gut äh voran. Gut Israel sowieso, aber aus besonderen Gründen und.
In den USA äh gab's jetzt auch eine Reihe von zumindest positiven Ankündigungen und auch positiven Meldungen. Also da nimmt das wohl gerade auch äh ganz gut Fahrt auf
und.
Man geht jetzt davon aus, glaube ich, die letzten Prognosen für die USA sind, dass im Juni alle durchgeimpft sein sollen dort.
Und das äh sagen ab Mai.
Wohl-Impfstoff für alle, die sich impfen lassen wollen, äh verfügbar sein wird. Das sind die letzten Ankündigungen aus der USA.
Ja, ich glaube, da sind wir doch doch noch ein Stück weit von äh entfernt, auch wenn jetzt die Lieferung extrem anzieht. Das ja, hängt dann eben auch von der Akzeptanz von all dem äh äh ab.
Was so der zweite große Punkt ist,
der, der dann gerade in der Debatte, warum wir jetzt nicht weiter verschärfen müssen, sondern weil warum wir jetzt eigentlich lockern können ist, dass ja die Alten, die über Achtzigjährigen,
ähm ja bald alle durchgeimpft sind und ansonsten bei den Jüngeren dann äh ja die Leute ja.
Fast alle ohne Symptome und auf jeden Fall nicht sterben und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt keine Maßnahmen mehr,
so und gut da sehen wir, dass also nach momentaner Planung.
Werden die Sechzigjährigen kaum vor August durch sein und.
Der Unterschied zwischen der Gruppe achtzig plus und,
sechzig bis neunundsiebzig in der Sterblichkeit äh ist halt zehn Prozent der achtzig Plus,
sind gestorben und fünf Prozent der sechzig bis neunundsiebzigjährigen sind gestorben. So, das heißt ähm.
Solange wir nicht auch die Sechzigjährigen durch haben,
so macht das macht das einen Unterschied in der Sterblichkeit von gerade mal,
der Hälfte ungefähr,
aus, so. Wenn wir die allerdings durchhaben, ähm dann ist es so bei den unter sechzigjährigen äh sind's halt
statt fünf Prozent nur noch null Komma zwei vier Prozent, also was ist das Faktor zwanzig weniger, aber,
selbst da sterben von einer Million Infizierten sind dort bisher ja äh zweihundertachtzigtausend in.
Dieser Altersgruppe gewesen und sechshundertsiebzig sind gestorben von den fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzigjährigen pro Millioneninfizierte und.
In der letzten Welle hatten wir halt um die zwei Millionen infiziert, das heißt es sind halt auch in der letzten Welle muss man sagen sind halt auch tausenddreihundert Menschen gestorben, die
ja mitten im Leben standen. Und ähm
Das ist halt, ja, wie gesagt, pro Million und jetzt können wir uns halt überlegen, wie viel Millionen wollen wir uns in der dritten Welle leisten eigentlich? Und so können wir dann hochrechnen, also sagt
es werden weniger werden aufgrund der Impfung aber selbst wenn die.
Wenn die Achtzigjährigen durchgeimpft werden wären, hätten wir immer noch zwischen zehn und fünfzehntausend Tote pro,
Millionen Infektionen. Und die andere Sache noch ähm die halt auch immer so ein bisschen aus.
Punktgerät, wenn man sagt, na ja, die meisten sind ja symptomfrei oder haben nur leichte Symptome abgesehen davon,
dass.
Ungefähr zehn Prozent der positiv getesteten ins Krankenhaus müssen und dort eine Krankenhausbehandlung, die im Durchschnitt zehntausend Euro,
kostet,
erhalten. Ähm und wenn es jeder zehnte ist, haben wir halt sozusagen proinfizierten mal tausend alleine an Krankenhauskosten.
Dann ist natürlich jeder infizierte, jeder, der positiv getestet wird, ist halt auch natürlich zurecht in Quarantäne und fällt halt auch für zehn Tage mindestens aus.
Vermutlich deutlich länger.
Und äh ja da kommen wir dann auch, wenn man das so in äh Boto in in Verlust an Bruttowertschöpfung umrechnet,
dann ist das so, dass.
Davon ausgehen, dass die Hälfte der Infizierten dann berufstätig äh ist, dann äh reden wir da halt von fünfhunderttausend ähm Leuten, die.
Wenn wir den Faktor zehn nehmen, die fünf Millionen Bruttoarbeitsstunden mal äh fünfzig äh Euro, das ist die Bruttowertschöpfung äh so. Ähm dann ja.
Man halt.
Auch schon äh ganz schnell auf mehrere Milliarden Euro an Verlust an Bruttowertschöpfung pro Million.
Infizierte, ganz unabhängig, ob Leute sterben äh jetzt, ja? Also das so eine jede einzelne Infektion.
Die wir haben, kostet uns mehrere tausend Euro. Das heißt, die letzte Welle, die wir uns erlaubt haben, äh hat alleine Belastungen äh fürs Gesundheitssystem und,
für die Wirtschaft.
Ohne Lokdown, ja? Also egal ob Lokdown gewesen wäre oder nicht, äh können wir davon ausgehen, dass uns die letzte Welle zwischen fünf und zehn Milliarden äh Euro gekostet hat, weil wir die Infektionen zugelassen haben.
Und ja.
Also so kann man halt auch sein Geld zum Fenster rauswerfen, indem man halt Leute sich anstecken lässt.
Ja ähm also wie gesagt.
Dann noch zu dem Thema, wir können's ja jetzt äh einfach mal laufen lassen und.
Die weiteren Prognosen machen wir dann vielleicht, wenn wir äh dann äh mit der Maßnahmendiskussion äh durch sind, weil letztlich die Frage natürlich der Maßnahmen und dann der,
Compliance ähm letztlich die es die.
Mit darüber entscheidet, wie viele Infektionen wir haben werden und wie viele nicht.
Wie sieht's denn aus, Tim? Hast du dir das mal genauer angeschaut? Die Öffnungsmatrix.
Na, sagen wir mal so, ich habe sie mir angeschaut.
Und äh ich fand's schon ganz bemerkenswert, dass wir diesmal überhaupt mal so eine Übersichtsgrafik bekommen haben von der Bundesregierung, die irgendwie andeutet oder versucht zu erklären, was hier jetzt gemacht werden soll von einer Matrix würde ich jetzt noch nicht sprechen,
ja also die die Öffnungsmatrix, die Irland ja schon vor vielen, vielen Monaten äh aufgemacht hat,
wo man irgendwie drauf schaut und sofort weiß, oh okay, alles klar, wenn das und das passiert, dann äh hat das folgende Konsequenzen in folgende Bereiche. Da fehlt dann hier so ein bisschen die äh Spaltenaufteilung für die Bereiche. Stattdessen haben wir hier eine etwas.
Unübersichtliche Grafik, die versucht verschiedene Öffnungsschritte zu erklären und was denn da so passieren würde
es lässt mich ein bisschen zweifelnd zurück zumal dann eben auch noch so Einschränkungen sind mit ja unter fünfzig Instinenz fünfzig bis einhundert et cetera ne
was dann irgendwie alles machen, was man dann machen könnte.
Okay, vielleicht gut vielleicht.
Versuchen wir mal, dass das grundlegende Prinzip äh erstmal äh zu erfassen oder die grundlegenden Prinzipien, äh die.
Die dahinter stehen. Also, ich glaube, ein grundlegendes Prinzip, weil über der steht halt wie.
Öffnung, erste Öffnungsschritt, zweite Öffnungsschritt, dritte Öffnungsschritt, vierte Öffnungsschritt, fünfte Öffnungsschritt. Das heißt äh.
Man hat sich auf Öffnungen festgelegt, also es steht nirgendwo gerade was von Verschärfungen. So, aber.
Auf keinen Fall weiter zurück als wir jetzt sind.
Ja. So, ähm jedenfalls ja.
Bis zum die fünften Öffnungsschritte sollen am fünften vierten erfolgen
aber dritter, vierter und fünfter Öffnungsschritt sind jeweils abhängig von der dann
geltenden Institz. So, abhängig davon, ob die zwischen fünf unter fünfzig ist, zwischen fünfzig und hundert
oder wenn's über hundert ist, fällt der dritte, vierte und fünfte Öffnungsschritt jeweils weg und es bleibt so.
Wie es ist.
Die Frage ist, wo gilt diese Inzidenz? Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist es eine Insidenz der Bundesländer.
Mhm.
Das ist aber auch hier irgendwie, finde ich schon mal sehr unzureichend kommuniziert, zumindest mit dieser äh veröffentlichten Grafik, da steht da irgendwie davon irgendwie gar nichts.
Sprich zwei Öffnungen sind jetzt mehr oder weniger bedingungslos. Äh die erste hat quasi schon äh stattgefunden. Das war jetzt am Montag, den ersten März. Da äh öffnen Schulen, in Klammern individuelle Regeln je Land.
Also nix klar geregelt. Jeder macht das anders, Kitas und Friseure äh plus regionale Öffnungen.
Mhm. Also Garten senden, ja.
Ja, in den Gartencenter sind hier noch nicht äh explizit.
Sind hier noch nicht, aber einige Länder haben das glaube ich schon vorgezogen.
Genau, also regionale Öffnung heißt so viel wie das ist zwar die Regel, aber es muss sich nicht hier dran halten.
Der zweite Öffnungsschritt sei dann ab dem achten dritten, also den nächsten Montag jetzt aus Perspektive dieser Sendung. Montag der achte dritte, das betrifft in Buchhandlung, Blumengeschäfte
aber nicht Baumärkte, ne.
Äh körpernahe Dienstleistung zum Teil mit tagesaktuellem Test und Fahr- und Flugschulen.
Mittagesaktuellen Test. Das ist sozusagen das einzige, was jetzt hier erstmal äh an Lockerungen explizit genannt wurde.
Kann man sagen, ja okay, ist nicht so viel, aber wir wissen ja alles äh alles, was in irgendeiner Form Bewegung erzeugt äh ja, erhöht eben die potenziellen Kontakte und das ist ja so ein bisschen das Problem.
Ab dem achten dritten dann in Abhängigkeit, wie du schon gesagt hast, der Exidenz.
Ja können dann weitere Dinge geöffnet werden. So und es gibt halt die Gruppe unter fünfzig und die Gruppe fünfzig bis einhundert.
Woraus ich jetzt mal lese mit über hundert keine Öffnung. Ja.
Ja
Und und unter fünfzig ja Einzel werden die Geschäfte aufgemacht mit Beschränkung der Kundenzahl zwischen fünfzig und hundert soll's halt Terminshopping geben.
Mit einem Kunden pro vierzig Quadratmeter und Terminbuch.
Ich meine, das ist etwas äh was ich finde, man aber grundsätzlich auch für Supermärkte hätte, einführen äh äh sollen oder zu.
Diese Terminbuchungs äh Geschichte oder nochmal eine deutliche Vereinzelung von Personen, aber dazu vielleicht noch später.
So und Musikgalerien, zoos botanische Gärten, Gedenkstätten, dann auch mit Terminbuchung und Dokumentation.
Im Falle der höheren Insidenzenau.
Im Falle der Höheren, also bei fünfzig bis hundert, genau,
Außensport soll irgendwie auch maximal zehn Personen kontaktfrei unter fünfzig.
Außensport mit maximal fünf Personen aus zwei Haushalten oder maximal zwanzig Kinder kontaktfrei bei fünfzig bis hundert.
Alle gemerkt.
Also für, ich lese das alles keinen Fußball. Ja, also da bräucht's dann irgendwie elf oder zweiundzwan.
Ja, also das haben sie maximal zehn Personen, ja, ist definitiv. Wir hatten ja zweiundzwanzig bräuchte man, glaube ich, äh oder gut spielt halt mit mit fünf gegen fünf.
Das ist auf jeden Fall auch noch sehr zurückhaltend so und wir können ja gleich nochmal sagen, was wir überhaupt davon halten, dass äh also ob wir überhaupt damit rechnen, dass das diese Institution überhaupt ähm unterschritten werden, hier diese fünfziger und hunderter Grenzen,
ja
Vierzehn Tage später frühestens am zweiundzwanzigsten dritten äh könnte halt dann irgendwie Außengastronomie starten.
Wenn's unter fünfzig ist, Theater, Kinos, Konzertobahnhäuser.
Und auch Sport kontaktfrei innen, Kontaktsport außen, also Fußball
unter fünfzig und ja also allein schon diese diese Grafik vorzulesen verdreht einem das Hirn, weil man einfach die ganze Logik äh dahinter nicht so richtig versteht so, also
warum die das jetzt hier nicht gleich so als Matrix äh äh gemacht haben. Ich.
Gibt's irgendwie keine ordentlichen Infografiker so, die man mal beschäftigen könnte.
Muss man doch echt äh besser machen. Na ja, also
es ist es ist es ist einfach schwierig das hier überhaupt sinnvoll zusammenfassen, aber im Wesentlichen ich mal sage so die Öffnungsperspektive ist überhaupt eine für den Einzelhandel, für die,
Außengastronomie für den Sport.
Und für so großflächige Orte und Gärten und Zoos und und so was. Das ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen,
alles was hier äh adressiert wird, ja? Geht da noch so ein bisschen weiter in der Zukunft mit vielleicht Freizeitveranstaltungen im Außenbereich
ähm grundsätzlich ist das alles noch sehr, sehr, sehr zurückhaltend. Also da wird nicht viel gelockert, wenn überhaupt.
Na ja also Theater, Konzert, Opernhäuser, Kinos.
Ist halt schon plus Freizeitveranstaltungen im Außenbereich mit maximal fünfzig Teilnehmenden. Also
ist es schon nichts aber und vor allen Dingen aber ist es kommt es natürlich recht früh, also
sagt, achte Dritte.
Zweiundzwanzigste dritte, fünfte vierte sind so jetzt die Termine für den dritten, vierten und fünften Öffnungsschrittes ist nicht mehr lange hin. Ja ähm und.
Ich meine, man kann jetzt sagen, dass dann sicherlich in Berlin und äh in den meisten anderen.
Bundesländern auch am achten dritten äh diese Variante Terminshopping im Einzelhandel mit einem Kunden pro vierzig Quadratmeter.
Musinen.
Galerien, zoosbotanische Gedenkstätten mit Terminbuchung und Dokumentation und Außensport mit maximal fünf Personen aus.
Zwei Haushalten und äh zwanzig oder zwanzig Kinder kontaktfrei und.
Sowieso auf jeden Fall die Buchhandlung Blumenmärkte.
Märkte ohne Termin Buchung und ohne Test körpernahe Dienstleistung, je nachdem.
Teilweise mit tagesaktuellem Test und Fahr- und Flugschulen mit Tagesaktuellem Test, also das ist jetzt sagen wir's jetzt ziemlich sicher kommt.
Ähm die Frage, die ich mir auch stelle, ich weiß nicht äh was passiert denn.
Wenn jetzt äh okay, wenn's wieder über hundert steigt, glaube ich, so an.
Sogenannte Notbremse. So.
Dann wird es wieder zurückgenommen.
Wird es alles wieder zurückgenommen auf den Stand vor dem siebten März. So. Also sozusagen auf den Stand dieser Woche.
Und.
Heißt letzten Endes, es gibt derzeit einfach noch keine Öffnungsperspektive für Innengastronomie, für Veranstaltungen, für Reisen.
Und Hotels, da wird dann erst in drei Wochen nochmal drüber äh beraten und damit es irgendwie Osterurlaub äh ohnehin sehr äh beschränkt möglich, ja. Ähm.
Aber wie der Tagesspiegel so schön festhält, reisen zum Beispiel nach Mallorca mit negativen Corona PCR Test werden schon möglich.
Genau. Homeoffice Regelung wird auch noch verlängert bis zum dreißigsten ab April die Regelung ist ja die es muss sozusagen ermöglicht werden, wenn die Arbeitnehmer das äh wollen.
Und äh sofern die Tätigkeiten das irgendwie
zulassen. Ich habe äh äh auf dem Internet habe ich eine schöne Zusammenfassung hier von äh Peter Wittkamp, äh die werde ich mal kurz äh einspielen, falls euch das jetzt alles verwirrt hat, hier nochmal die Zusammenfassung der Maßnahmen in äh knapper Form.
Ja, das äh hätten wir jetzt natürlich besser zusammenfassen können. Ach Gott.
Okay, die eigentliche Frage, die er jetzt auf dem Horizont ist in Bezug auf diese Beschlüsse ist doch.
Haben wir eigentlich überhaupt irgendeine Chance auf fünfzig bis einhundert oder überhaupt unter einhundert in den nächsten Wochen.
Ja
Also in den nächsten Wochen schon noch ähm sage ich mal. Leider äh ist mit meiner schönen, kaputten.
Äh Tabelle.
Jetzt wäre sie genau die Richtige, ne?
Genau, aber nur mal, vielleicht finde ich ja irgendwo ein Bundesland mit der passenden Instit.
Also in Thüringen ist man auf jeden Fall über hundert. So, da läuft halt gar nix.
Ja, in einigen Ländern, wie gesagt, läuft gar nichts. Ähm und wir.
Werden das auch maximal ähm vier Wochen lang äh genießen, die,
unter hundert Institanz, so wie es im Moment aussieht. Also es ist jetzt.
Weniger schlimm als wir letzte Woche noch befürchtet hatten. Also es ist nicht so asi zweihundert werden.
Wir jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht reißen, äh wie ich äh prognostiziert hatte. Möglich ist es schon, aber am wahrscheinlichsten,
ist es so, dass wir dann ja irgendwann im März gegen Ende März spätestens die hundert
werden in.
Berlin zumindest und wahrscheinlich in den meisten anderen Bundesländern auch in verschiedenen Ländern liegen wir halt auch drüber und.
Ja. Ähm also ich hatte.
So schon gesagt, mein erster Eindruck ist.
Es ist jetzt kein äh kompletter Totalschaden. Was passiert ist hier, also insbesondere.
Gibt es halt jetzt wenigstens erstmals klare Regelungen. Ich meine, das ist ja eine Premiere, so nach einem Jahr.
Pandemie haben wir endlich mal Regelungen, die besagen.
Welcher Institanz denn konkret was passieren soll beziehungsweise Lockerungen zurückgenommen werden sollen. Das hatten wir vorher nicht einfach gelockert und dann war's halt.
Aufgabe der Politik irgendwann gegebenenfalls aufgrund irgendwelcher.
Kriterien so subjektiven Kriterien dann eventuell wieder neue Maßnahmen einzuführen, was dann halt wir ja wissen äh fast zwei Monate zu spät passiert ist. So jetzt haben wir immerhin so äh,
positiv gesagt, ähm ja, haben wir halt äh in klare Ansagen. Ich meine.
Gut die fünfziger Insidenz oder die fünfzig bis hunderter Institz, das ist halt, na ja, wie gesagt, das ist halt Höhepunkt, erste Welle.
Und.
Ja, man kann vielleicht ein bisschen toleranter äh äh sein jetzt in der zweiten Welle, weil wir halt mehr Tests haben und äh Masken für alle und so,
Kann man halt schon oder hätte man vielleicht ein bisschen höher gehen können theoretisch aber ja.
Die fünfzig oder die hundert sind jetzt hal.
Rein fiktive Zahlen, die nicht auf irgendwelchen wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen oder äh Risiken oder so.
Basieren, sondern ähm ja, man bei einer Institanz von fünfzig ist es halt immer noch so, dass halt.
Dann so einer von drei oder vierhundert Menschen, die draußen rumlaufen, gerade infiziert ist.
So, das ist halt ja nicht so richtig sicher. Also jetzt auch nicht so super gefährlich, aber äh ja entspannt ist es nicht und.
Bei der Zahl der Kontakte, die auch stattfinden ist es so, dass wahrscheinlich jeder zehnte täglich einem äh äh infizierten begegnet.
Im Schnitt. Hm.
Kann man halt jetzt, ja,
Ist okay, aber je und dabei muss es natürlich, wenn man einem infizierten begegnet jetzt nicht zwar Ansteckung äh kommen. Das ist dann auch nochmal äh
je nachdem kommt's natürlich auf die Situation an, aber sagen wir so, jeder zehnte bei Institanz fünfzig hat jeder Zehnte die Gelegenheit sich äh äh
täglich anzustecken oder man selber hat die Gelegenheit sich alle zehn Tage so im Schnitt anzustecken. Ja.
Was ja bei diesen ganzen Maßnahmen jetzt eben so ein bisschen äh rausgefallen ist. Also es gibt jetzt sozusagen die Maßnahme, Schulen können wieder öffnen, aber es gibt halt irgendwie äh im schlimmsten Fall fällt es halt alles auf die Regelung vom siebten äh März zurück, aber.
Dann sind die Schulden immer noch geöffnet. Also Schulen, Schließen ist in dem aktuellen Plan keine Option. Schulen bleiben jetzt irgendwie offen
Wobei da die Detailregelungen glaube ich
erstmal von Land zu Land dann auch wieder unterschiedlich sind. Klar, wie sollte es auch anders sein? Und äh die Handhabung auch ein bisschen äh problematischer. Ich habe da jetzt ehrlich gesagt keinen besonders guten Überblick, soweit ich das aber mitbekommen habe.
Entfällt so ein bisschen die Pflicht, die Kinder auch wirklich dahin zu schicken.
Auf der anderen Seite werden dann aber auch diese ganzen Online-Bettachings äh Maßnahmen nicht garantiert.
Nach dem Motto ja muss vielleicht nicht kommen in die Schule, aber dann muss halt sehen wie dein Kind irgendwie an die Hausaufgaben rankommt das finde ich total absurd.
In der Praxis habe ich gehört, dass irgendwie ähm ja von einem äh äh.
Auch jetzt anekdotisch, der meinte, es seine Kinder sind die einzigen in der Klasse, äh die zu Hause bleiben,
So, ansonsten alle Eltern äh haben ihre Kinder wohl in der Klasse äh in die Schule geschickt, sobald es möglich war,
und ich denke ja, dass man davon ausgehen kann, dass halt diese.
Meine ich find's gut, dass die Kinder nicht hin müssen, also ist zumindest der
äh die Strafandrohung, äh dass es Leute nicht ins Gefängnis müssen, äh äh die ihre Kinder zu Hause behalten. Das finde ich halt richtig. Aber der Druck
natürlich die Kinder zur Schule zu schicken, ist natürlich trotzdem extrem groß, dass wir eigentlich erwarten können, dass dann ja
das schwierig ist für Eltern die ihre Kinder zu Hause.
Ja auch für die Kinder ist das natürlich ein Problem, ne, dass dass die dann wenn du die einzigen sein sollen und dann sind sie auch noch benachteiligt, weil sie irgendwie nicht den Unterricht zumindest so in der Form, wie er bisher gelaufen ist, machen können, was was willst du dann da machen, ne
Also das das ja, das ist äh eine unschöne Sache und dieses Dogma, das jetzt um die Schulen auf jeden Fall wieder eröffnen müssen, egal was ist
Na ja, das wird uns auf die Füße fallen. Äh parallel dazu kommt dann eben so die Ausrede, so naja, aber die Lehrer werden ja geimpft. Ja, hurra.
Abgesehen davon, dass es noch sehr lange dauern wird, bis da ein erklärlicher Teil der Lehrer und Lehrerinnen auch wirklich geimpft sind.
Sind das halt nur die Lehrer, ne? Es geht ja um die äh
auch mal eben so ein bisschen um die äh Kids, die es dann halt wieder schön in die Haushalte äh tragen und das ist äh dann das nächste Problem. Ach Göttchen, also es fällt einem schon ein bisschen schwer, äh da auch nur drüber nachzudenken.
Ja
Und das alles halt bei diesen relativ hohen Zahlen, bei denen wir äh sind. Und kaum und das hatten wir ja auch.
Befürchtet, als wir hier vor zwei, drei Wochen das erste Mal von,
Okay, Lockerungen sind geplant, ja? Sachsen kündigt irgendwas an. Äh gesprochen haben wir ja schon befürchtet, dass also allein die Ankündigung dieser Lockerung.
Die zu dem Zeitpunkt halt noch überhaupt nicht vollzogen waren, sondern irgendwie überhaupt erstmal nur erwegt werden, dass das schon eine Änderung der Zahlen.
Auslösen kann, weil das einfach die Erfahrung ist, die wir jetzt in der ganzen Krise gemacht haben, dass eigentlich die ganzen Infektionszahlen sehr viel mehr dem.
Dem Newcycle folgen als irgendwelchen konkret verordneten Maßnahmen und wir hatten ja vorhin schon das Beispiel hier mit der Mobilität, die einfach schon wieder auf dem Normalzustand ist. Zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo wir letzte Mal Höhepunkt der Krise hatten.
Zeigt, dass dass irgendwie alles nicht zusammenpasst.
Und von daher kann man nur davon ausgehen, dass es halt jetzt so weitergehen wird. Die Zahlen werden halt einfach steigen. Und dann sind wir halt in vier Wochen wieder da. So.
Im Prinzip der ganze Erfolg in Anführungsstrichen der letzten Monate, seit November weitgehend aufgebraucht.
Also wir haben uns ja ich meine waren jetzt mühsam über mehrere Monate runtergearbeitet und äh ja,
Äh werden das wahrscheinlich in kürzester Zeit jetzt wieder verspielen, äh so wie es aussieht. Ich hoffe natürlich nicht. Ich hoffe natürlich auch immer, dass äh ja.
Äh sich in Grenzen halten wird und ähm ich hatte auch eigentlich,
die große Welle, also das Anlaufen der Welle ähm erst ja für für.
Mitte März äh gesehen. Es ging dann halt ein bisschen früher los jetzt, aber.
Jetzt noch zum Glück relativ verhaltenlos, aber die Zahlen steigen halt und,
steigende Zahlen sind halt die falsche Richtung und bei steigenden Zahlen kann man nicht lockern. So einfach ist das, ja? Also mal jetzt diese ganze Regelung sich anguckt so, das ist halt steht halt
eigentlich komplett, also jede Lockerung äh hier steht halt komplett äh ja im Widerspruch zu allen.
Wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen und zu jeder Logik, ja? Ich, ich lockere nicht, wenn die Zahlen steigen, Punkt, ja, egal bei welcher Institanz oder sagen wir mal so, sobald.
Ist die Institenz äh übereinstellig ist, äh, lockere ich nicht ja, wenn.
Es steigt. Wenn's sinkt, okay, kann man drüber reden, bei jeder Institanz äh kann man bei sinkenden Zahlen äh sich
Schlichtes Überlegen, Sinn macht es natürlich trotzdem nicht, weil man will halt so schnell wie möglich nach unten kommen und dann lockern und nicht unterwegs lockern. Ähm,
ja? Das ist irgendwie, ich weiß nicht.
Vergleich das irgendwie mit einer, weiß ich nicht, zu einer langen, super langen Autoreise, ne
äh wo man, wo dann aber ja
alle zehn Minuten irgendjemand äh möchte, dass man anhält, um entweder irgendwas zu essen oder aufs Klo zu gehen oder sich die Beine zu vertreten, so
und alle genervt sind von der Fahrt, weil's halt eng ist so, aber äh ja äh
am Ende man halt zwei bis drei Mal so lange unterwegs ist, als wenn alle irgendwie mal ja koordiniert aufs Klo gehen würden und dann halt die Zähne zusammenbeißen und dann endlich,
Ball ans Ziel kommen und da ist dann Komfort und da ist dann Ruhe und leckeres Essen und so so dieses Bild kam mir halt halt äh gerade und was wir,
machen ist, dann auch äh ja wir
beschleichen äh vor uns hin und halten irgendwie an an jeder Ecke und ähm ja.
Unseren Podcast weiterzureichen, immer nicht so einfach äh ist, den muss man einfach entspannt ähm hören.
Beim Tee gibt's von mir noch einen Tipp auf ein Video aus der Redaktion von Quarks, ehemals Quarks und Co.
Haben sie sich jetzt irgendwie
und das so ein kurzes Video unter dem Titel lockern, trotz Corona Mutation, warum das eine verdammt schlechte Idee ist. Und da ist dann nochmal schön zusammen kondensiert das, was wir hier eigentlich auch mal besprechen. Das hätten wir jetzt also auch alles in drei Minuten sagen können.
Wenn wir Quarks wären, sind wir aber nicht.
Genau.
Zu den wie gesagt zu den zu den Schulthemen noch da habe ich ja am äh Mittwoch.
Denke ich Mittwoch oder Donnerstag einen Tweet abgesetzt, wo ich dann bisschen unter Feuer geraten bin, weil ich mich da auch,
etwas ja unpräzise, man könnte auch sagen
falsch ausgedrückt, aber zumindest so wie ich mich ausgedrückt habe, hat das halt äh dann doch.
Zu Missverständnissen geführt und zwar ähm sind mir halt die,
englischen Reports die aktuellen in die Finger äh gefallen und dort gibt es ganz nette äh Grafiken, die,
besagen.
Wie viel Prozent der infizierten, denn in der Zeit wo sie sich infiziert haben, äh was die Leute in der Zeit gemacht haben oder wo sie waren.
Äh ich habe das
so ein bisschen so dargestellt als wäre das sagen wo sich die Leute,
tatsächlich infizieren. Das ist es natürlich nicht und da mich dann halt auch ganz viele Leute halt ganz schnell drauf hingewiesen, was ich gut fand. Ich hab's dann deswegen auch nicht gelöscht, also ich lösche halt auf auf Twitter
ungerne freuen, wenn's dann eine Diskussion äh darum gibt und ich habe das dann halt eingeräumt und dann auch sagen mich dann auch korrigiert
aber da ja auch viele Leute auf Twitter nicht den ganzen Sweat äh lesen äh äh haben die das halt auch teilweise nicht gesehen und.
Der Punkt, warum ich da so ähm.
Ja auch ein bisschen aufgeregt äh war und mich so ein bisschen ja zu sehr aus dem Fenster gelehnt habe, Formulierungsmäßig war, weil dort äh der Balken Shopping.
Ähm doch ein äh großer Balken ist, sogar der der höchste Balken. Das heißt was die.
Meisten Leute jetzt in England getan haben, die sich gerade angesteckt haben war einkaufen gehen, kann man sagen, ja klar, jeder geht einkaufen, aber.
Also erstens ich nicht äh so. Also ich minimiere das so. Ich bin alle drei oder vier Wochen mal einkaufen. Ich weiß nicht, wie wie häufig du einkaufen.
Ja von so kleinst Besorgungen zwischendurch mal abgesehen so die großen Einkäufe versuche ich so auf alle zwei Wochen zu stri,
aber das hat auch damit zu tun, dass ich mich mittlerweile sehr auf so Essenslieferdienste eingeschossen habe. Von daher kann ich mir das dadurch ganz gut ersparen.
So und.
Dieser Balken war halt aber nur deswegen auch aktuell der größte, weil gerade äh Schulen und Kitas geschlossen waren in England. Davor war halt dann äh der größte.
Irgendwie interessanterweise.
Kitas beziehungsweise Teilnahme an Jahr.
Ausbildender Kinderbetreuung oder wie die das, wie die das da genannt äh äh haben und ähm ja.
Es ist zwar richtig, dass sagen in dieser Statistik, dass man sagen kann, gut nur, weil sie in,
Aktivität oder an diesem Ort waren in der Zeit, wo sie sich angesteckt haben, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass sie sich dort wirklich angesteckt haben.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir und das äh wenn man jetzt auf die auf die passenden deutschen Zahlen guckt ähm wo.
Dass aufgegliedert ist nach tatsächlich wo sich die Leute wahrscheinlich angesteckt haben. Ähm also wo andere Fragen äh gestellt wurden.
Und da ist es so, dass achtzig Prozent.
Der Fälle keine Ahnung haben wo sie sich angesteckt haben. Ja? So.
Wenn man sich dann die Frage stellt, okay ähm achtzig Prozent haben keine Ahnung, wo sie sich angesteckt haben. Was haben die denn in der Zeit gemacht.
Aha, die meisten waren einkaufen von denen, hm. Ähm.
Wenn man dann noch überlegt, ich meine, wir tragen ja nicht umsonst äh FFP zwei Masken beim Einkaufen, bei Einkaufen ist gefährlich.
Und wenn man dann guckt, wie das dann so mit der Masken,
Passqualität und der Maskendisziplin so mit Nase raushängen und weiß ich nicht was und
dann teilweise natürlich nicht maskierten Kassierinnen äh und und so. Also ja, einkaufen.
Man kann sich beim Einkaufen anstecken und äh ich wüsste jetzt nicht, warum, wenn dort erstens eine.
Ansteckungswahrscheinlichkeit vorhanden sind und die meisten Leute angeben, dass sie einkaufen waren, äh finde ich, ist es jetzt nicht
ich sag mal so 'n super weiter Gedankensprung oder Gedankenschritt zu vermuten dass ja Einkaufen einfach 'n großer Faktor,
sein dürfte. Nach wie vor, so,
auch in der jetzigen Situation, wo die meisten Läden zu haben. Und wenn wir das wissen, ist natürlich, wenn wir jetzt sagen, mehr Shoppingmöglichkeiten noch eröffnen, dürfte das die ganze Situation nicht verbessern.
Die zweite Sache ist, dass in England äh auch und dass da wurden dann andere äh äh Fragen äh gestellt, also das ist sozusagen die Zahl der Cluster.
Und die Zahl der Infizierten, die Zahl der Ausbrüche in Kitas und Schulen dort ganz gut erfasst ist, im Gegensatz.
Bei uns, bei uns ist das nur, also gibt es auch ähnliche Statistiken, die aber irgendwie
überhaupt nicht wirklich zusammenpassen, weil äh wenn man sich dann die RKI-Statistiken anguckt, stellt man fest, dass sich in Schulen und Kitas ungefähr halb so viele Leute angesteckt haben, wie in Heimen,
sowohl Mitarbeiter äh wie auch äh Bewohner oder also dort Tätige oder Besucher wie auch auch immer
und äh das passt aber überhaupt nicht dann äh sagen zu den.
Beim beim beim Tracing oder Tracking, also in der Statistik, wo sich die Leute angesteckt haben, wo man eh nur von den zwanzig Prozent weiß.
Tauchen Schulen so gut wie gar nicht auf. Also will sagen ähm ich glaube äh.
Wir haben also die deutschen Zahlen passen überhaupt nicht zu den englischen ähm speziell was Schulen und Kinder beziehungsweise die
eine Erfassung der Zahlen, die aufgrund eines anderen Gesetzes stattfindet und die Erfassung aufgrund des Infektionsschutzgesetzes ähm sagen.
Für Normalbürger und die für in Krankenhäusern, Schulen oder Pflegearbeitenden oder Untergebrachten, das sind zwei total verschiedene Erfassungswege und das, was,
aus den beiden rauskommt, passt halt überhaupt nicht zusammen. Also insofern kann man nur konstatieren.
Wir wissen von achtzig Prozent der Infektion nicht, wo sie stattfinden. Wir wissen nur, dass die meisten Leute in der Zeit, wo sie sich angesteckt haben, einkaufen waren jedenfalls.
Engländer. Bei uns gibt es keine vergleichbare äh Studie oder Frage offenbar die, die gestellt wird und es ist sogar so, ähm.
Wenn du beim Gesundheitsamt dann sagst, naja, ich fahre einkaufen in der Zeit, ja, haben sie in eine Maske getragen, ja okay, dann war dieses Einkaufen per Definition per Risikodefinition halt kein riskanter Kontakt
und äh ja.
Taucht halt dann auch nirgendwo auf. So wird es halt bei uns gehandhabt. Also bei uns ist auf der einen Seite,
nach Gesundheitsamt oder nach Erfassung von Infektionsursachen,
Einkaufen sicher. Auf der einen Seite, aber auf der anderen Seite wissen wir halt ganz genau, dass es das nicht ist. Wir wissen nur nicht wirklich genau, wie unsicher es ist, aber.
Ja ähm hm und,
Dazu noch nur größenordnungsmäßig Infektionsgefahr, hat mir auch schon mal den Korona Schutzfaktor in der Sendung
erwähnt, dass so Masken, je nachdem, welche Maske und wer sie trägt, man so einen Corona-Schutzfaktor von zehn bis hundert erreichen kann, um die dreißig bei einer FFB zwei Maske und.
Es gibt jetzt ganz gute Zahlen,
auch ähm um Ansteckung in Innenräumen und Ansteckung außen miteinander zu vergleichen und,
je nach natürlich Fitterungsverhältnissen ist es aber auch 'ne Größenordnung von fünfzehn bis dreißig zwischendrin und draußen, das heißt fang an.
Auch über den Daumen sagen äh äh draußen ohne Maske ist,
ungefähr dasselbe wie drin Windmaske so und beides ist nicht ungefährlich, wenn halt Abstände nicht eingehalten werden oder zu viele Leute auf einem Haufen hängen,
dann kann man sich dabei auch anstellen.
Ja, das äh vielleicht dazu, aber äh ja ich habe trotzdem daraus die Lehre gezogen, ich muss halt manchmal dann gerade, wenn ich vielleicht ein bisschen begeistert äh
bin über eine neue Erkenntnis äh dann
vielleicht doch nochmal eine Stunde warten und darüber nachdenken äh und dann meine Begeisterung erstmal wieder sinken lassen, mich dann vielleicht ein bisschen.
Präziser und vorsichtiger äh äußern auf Twitter, weil äh ja.
Gut, dann,
gucken wir da nochmal ein bisschen, was so im Bereich von äh Impfstoffen äh so passiert ist. Da gab's ein paar interessante Meldungen.
Zunächst einmal sieht es wohl so aus, dass die EMA, also die für Impfstoffe, zuständige, europäische Behörde jetzt wohl auch sputnick fünf,
auf dem Radar hat. Zur Erinnerung Sputnik fünf ist der,
Russische Impfstoff, der ja schon sehr früh angekündigt war, wo dann irgendwie behauptet wurde, man hätte in Russland da auch schon irgendwie erste Leute mitgeimpft und dann gab's den großen Aufschrei und überhaupt und äh
Ihr habt das ja noch gar nicht mal richtig zu Ende äh getestet. Technisch verbirgt sich dahinter ein Viktorimpfstoff,
genauso wie der von Astra Zeneker, also dass man einen anderen Virus nimmt und da halt äh die Inkredenzien entsprechend austauscht, um den,
Virus selber eigentlich nur so als Transportvehikel zu benutzen, um dann.
Den Körper wie bei allen anderen auch dazu zu bringen, dieses Bike-Protein vom Saaskoff zwei zu produzieren.
Sodass dann eben der Körper darauf eine Reaktion anstoßen kann mit der Besonderheit, dass hier eben zwar auch in zwei.
Dosen geimpft wird, aber,
in der ersten und in der zweiten Dosis jeweils ein anderer Träger Virus verwendet wird, also ein AD sechsundzwanzig und dann ein AD fünf, die sind irgendwie durchnummeriert, das tut jetzt nichts weiter zur Sache.
Sind aber humanovieren, also welche die normalerweise ja den Menschen befallen.
OK, mhm. Ja, dem wird jetzt wohl auch eine hohe Wirksamkeit nachgesagt.
Also das sieht nach den bisher bekannten Zwischenergebnissen ganz gut
aus, also hier wird von einer Wirksamkeit von einundneunzig Komma sechs Prozent gesprochen, das heißt, es liegt dann so im groben auch da, wo man eben
den Astral Sinneka äh Impfstoff sieht beziehungsweise auch so in dieser Region von den MRNA-Impfstoffen, also durchaus sinnvoll,
heißt aber jetzt nicht, dass der jetzt schon bald zugelassen werden würde. Also erstmal liegt noch überhaupt gar kein Zulassungsantrag vor
So, was da halt gemacht wird, ist das eben dieser Spucknick fünf jetzt auch in dieses Rollierende Review Verfahren mit reingenommen wird. Also das quasi so,
dass jetzt am laufenden Meter so denn neue Erkenntnisse da sind, die auch schon an die EMA übermittelt werden und dort schon mal so vorab begutachtet,
werden, sodass in dem Moment, wo.
Die Russen beschließen so okay, alles klar. Jetzt wollen wir den auch mal in der EU beantragen, dass dann eben.
Komplett bei A angefangen wird, sondern man im Prinzip schon zwischen Ergebnisse mit eingepreist hat und dann eben den eigentlichen Zulassungsantrag mit den finalen Ergebnissen dann nochmal.
Berücksichtigt. Könnte also bedeuten, dass in unser Impfportfolio auch Sputnique fünf zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt noch mit dazu kommt, aber,
ich hab jetzt zumindest hier keine Information gefunden oder Einschätzung wann denn das sein könnte? Ja.
Sicherlich keine schlechte Nachricht. In Ungarn wird er ja auch schon verimpft, weil die Ungarn halt gesagt haben,
Wir warten nicht auf Europa, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal so und haben dem dann halt die entsprechenden Notfallzulassung gegeben.
Da habe ich jetzt auch noch keine Information dadrüber, in welchem Umfang das stattgefunden hat oder ob's da vielleicht sogar schon irgendwelche äh Ergebnisse davon gibt. Ich denke, das äh liegt noch so ein bisschen in der Zukunft.
Und Iran und äh wird auch noch erwähnt und Serbien weiß ich äh.
Ja, also verschiedene Länder haben den sozusagen schon äh angenommen, Türkei äh sind, glaube ich, auch ein paar Dosierungen gelandet, aber das scheint mir alles noch kein.
Nennenswerten Umfang zu haben. Zumindest weiß ich das nicht.
Dann gab's ja viel Aufregung um den Astra Zenika-Impfstoff in Deutschland. Das dürften ja alle mitbekommen haben, diese große Problematik, dass äh sich sozusagen in den Medien da so ein paar Zahlen verdreht haben und
durch so ein paar Berichterstattungen und dann auf einmal behauptet wurde, wäre ja nur zu acht Prozent äh wirksam, was nicht der Fall ist, sondern da
wurden dann halt Zahlen.
Durcheinander gebracht und das hat alles zu einer großen Konfusion geführt, vor allem auch, weil dies Stiko, also die permanente oder wie heißt das.
Ständige genau die ständige Impfkommisskommission in Deutschland.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Zulassung durchaus korrekt
bemängelt hat das ja hier noch nicht die ausreichenden vorgeschriebenen Testzahlen zusammengekommen wären für Leute die älter als fünfundsechzig sind und deswegen wurde Astra Cenica halt erstmal nur für die Altersgruppen unter fünfundsechzig zugelassen.
Und auch wenn das alles technisch ganz richtig war, kann man wohl konstatieren, dass es in der Außenkommunikation auf jeden Fall nicht gut gelaufen ist. Ne, weil einfach die Wahrnehmung irgendwie war, na ja, irgendwie, das ist ja hier nur so.
Noch nicht mal.
Zweiter Klasse. Mhm.
All diese ganzen Aussagen, das das ist
also Astracenica wirkt und Astra Cinica wirkt auch bei alten Leuten, das ist jetzt auch belegt und deswegen hat die Impfkommission jetzt auch angekündigt, dass sie das eben auch auf ältere Leute erweitern wird.
Und ich meine und auf der anderen Seite muss man halt sagen, gut, also die Engländer haben einfach losgelegt,
Damit die hatten das halt anders gemacht. In England wurden halt jetzt äh ja mehrere Millionen Leute damit geimpft oder über eine Million glaube ich mit Astra Sinica mittlerweile und.
Ähm ja
hat man halt gesehen, dass der sogar bei alten Leuten nach der ersten Dosis
schneller wirkt, also dass sich die Immunität schneller aufbaut als bei Biotech nur geringfügig, also macht am Ende kein Unterschied, aber ähm ja
Also dieses ganze Hika war halt nur nach Vorsicht geschuldet und.
Hm die Vorsicht, also das Kalkül, ja
kann man verstehen, dass sie einfach nach sich entschieden haben, einfach nach dem Buchstaben, nach den Vorschriften vorzugehen,
auf der anderen Seite.
Sind mir keine Fälle bekannt, wo jetzt einen Impfstoff bei älteren Menschen halt nicht
verimpft werden kann. Also jetzt sagen bei anderen Impfstoffen so. Das Einzige ist, dass der halt schlechter wirkt, ja
Und ja, kann man jetzt sagen, okay, äh
wussten nicht, wie gut er wirkt äh oder oder nicht und wollten jetzt nicht vielleicht nicht überflüssigerweise Leute mit einem Impfstoff impfen, der dann vielleicht nicht ganz so
gut wirkt. Ähm aber unterm Strich kann man sagen,
was auch immer die Engländer da gemacht haben äh,
dieser das Risiko, das sie vielleicht eingegangen sind, äh Leute umsonst zu impfen ist, aufgegangen, weil es war halt nichts dran. Das hat sich halt.
Gezeigt, äh, ja.
Der ist wirksam und genauso sicher und es gibt keine Probleme damit und ja man hätte das nicht tun müssen.
Ist aber passiert. Was in dem Zusammenhang noch bemerkenswert ist, ist das jetzt hier aber auch der Impfabstand auch gleich auf zwölf Wochen festgelegt wird.
Auch das basiert ja auf neuen Erkenntnissen, dass das eben zu keinem äh Nachteil äh führt.
Der Vorteil, den es natürlich hat, ist, dass man die vorhandenen Impfdosen ähm.
In mehr Erstimpfungen überführen kann, bevor man dann eben später mit dem selben Impfstoff nochmal eine zweite Impfung durchführt
Zwölf Wochen ist auch der Abstand den Astra Zenica sozusagen angibt. Also man nutzt einfach den maximalen Range, der hier äh empfohlen worden ist vom Hersteller und das wird dann einfach zu mehr Erstimpfung führen,
So, ganz klar. Und Leute, die schon mal eine Saaskoff zwei Infektionen hatten, können den auch kriegen.
Da wird aber auch äh empfohlen nur eine Impfung auch nur vorzunehmen. Also im Prinzip, wenn man schon mal infiziert war
kriegt man dann frühestens sechs Monate nach der Infektion allerdings äh nur eine Impfung und dann ist das mehr oder weniger die Booster-Impfung, weil man eben schon davon ausgehen kann, dass so eine.
Animimunisierung stattgefunden hat.
Ja okay, kann man so zur äh Kenntnis nehmen. Ich würde halt meinen so, hm.
Wie sicher ist man sich eigentlich, wie groß diese Erstimmungisierung durch die Infektion gewesen ist.
Also die die Zahlen, die ich kenne für Astra Sinneka ist
dass fünf Wochen nach der Erstimpfung sie bei fünfundneunzig Prozent der infizierten eine Hospitalisierung verhindert.
Ja? So, das war das, was man in der Studie gemessen hat äh und vierundneunzig Prozent.
So und ich denke, das ist schon mal ein ganz guter Schritt. Das ist jetzt sagen, nee, sind jetzt nicht die.
Ähm ja, es ist jetzt noch nicht die endgültige Wirkung, aber ich finde, das ist schon mal äh ziemlich gut.
Bisschen Aufregung äh gibt's allerdings um Impfexporte.
Und da äh hat jetzt die EU einen Bann erlassen und in Italien wurde das jetzt auch schon mal durchgesetzt, das heißt.
Astrazedika, was halt in der EU äh produziert wird,
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das genau produziert wird, aber in dem Fall ähm wenn sozusagen Impfstoff die EU verlassen soll, dann muss dann entsprechende Exportlizenz auch für beantragt werden.
Das ist jetzt untersagt,
weil ja Astra Senika, die hatten ja äh etwas biefig, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir da hier drauf eingegangen sind. Ich glaube, wir haben das so ein bisschen übersprungen das Thema
da gab's ja eine eine riesige Auseinandersetzung, dass Astra Cineca zwar Zusagen gemacht hat, die aber nicht halten konnte.
Und da sind ja auch ein paar äh schon ziemlich frei gedreht und da äh sind so diverse Drohungen erlassen worden. Ich kriegte zum Einzelnen nicht so zusammengefasst Tatsache ist, äh Asracinica hat
quasi seine Zusagen, seine ursprünglichen Sohn nicht einhalten äh können und dementsprechend wird jetzt Astra Zenika verboten,
Impfstoffe zu liefern in andere Länder. Dieser Lieferexport gilt aber also dieser Bann auf diesen Export
gilt jetzt nicht für Entwicklungsländer, ja? Ähm also die dürfen nach wie vor äh beliefert werden, aber es.
Ja und Partnerländer.
Und und Partnerländer dürften auch äh beliefert werden, also Israel, Schweiz, Ukraine wurde da, glaube ich, genannt, die dürften auch, ne. Konkret wurde aber jetzt in Italien äh eine Lieferung nach Australien gestoppt zum Beispiel, ne? Also da greift das sozusagen,
na ja.
Ja und in San Diego in den USA wurden jetzt auch äh Menschenaffen.
Geimpft. Das fand ich ja irgendwie eine interessante Meldung. Also es gab wohl im ähm.
Anfang dieses Jahres haben sie äh Flachland.
Westliche Flachland Gorillas heißen die, ähm die in diesem Zoo waren, die äh haben sich wohl über einen Tierpfleger angesteckt, der offenbar symptomatische.
Infektion erlitten hat und ja, die haben die irgendwie getestet und hat tatsächlich das Virus bei diesen Gorillas.
Ähm festgestellt.
Und es ist ja sowieso schon vor einem Jahr wurde eben gewarnt, dass unter anderem Menschenaffen wohl auch durch diese Pandemie gefährdet sein können, weil.
Durchaus davon auszugehen ist, dass die so ähnlich wie Menschen ähm ja nicht so nicht nur sich infizieren können, sondern eben auch an dieser Infektion sterben können.
Ja und jetzt ist von einer Firma namens Soetis ähm so eine Firma, die so Tierpharma äh Sachen macht, also Impfstoffe für,
und Medikamente vielleicht auch, weiß ich nicht genau, für Tiere herstellt. Ähm die hat jetzt einen speziellen Impfstoff entwickelt. Ich habe leider keine Informationen dazu gefunden, auf welcher Basis, auf der technischen Basis, der funktioniert.
Und wurden jetzt irgendwie fünf Bonobos und fünf Orang-Utans in diesem Zoo geimpft.
Zeigt aber nochmal ganz klar, womit wir es hier auch zu tun haben, nämlich so wirklich zum zu notischen Infektionskreis.
Das hatten wir ja nun auch schon, dass Nerze und andere Tiere durchaus dieses Virus nicht nur aufnehmen können, sondern eben auch wieder an Menschen weitergeben können.
Und das äh es sich hier eben bei Leibe nicht nur um eine Pandemie handelt, die Menschen.
Gefährdet, sondern eben auch die Tiere und könnte durchaus sein, dass wir noch mehr von solchen Infektionen sehen werden und von solchen Impfungen vor allem sehen werden.
Mal gucken, wer da alles noch wer da noch alles geimpft wird.
Ja und zum Schluss müssen wir nochmal auf so 'ne Meldung eingehen die diese Woche nochmal rumging. Ich hatte die schon vor einiger Zeit gelesen und mich so 'n bisschen gewundert was es denn damit auf sich hat. Ich weiß nicht ob du das irgendwie auch mitbekommen hast.
Am Rande.
So am Rande, ne? Genau. Da gibt es einen Herrn. Ähm Winfried Stöcker.
Und Winfried Stöcker ist irgendwie auch äh Mediziner und äh auch in der Immunologie unterwegs schon seit längerem äh,
durchaus,
kann auch irgendwie eine Firma gegründet, Euroimmun, die es schon länger gab und die ja vor ein paar Jahren auch wohl ganz gewinnbringend verkauft hat.
Und äh die Meldung gab's schon dazu, dass er behauptet, äh einen Impfstoff entwickelt zu haben.
Gegen neunzehn.
Und jetzt gab's auch nochmal bei Spiegel TV so eine Berichterstattung da drüber, die jetzt gerade so ein bisschen durch die äh Netze äh weitergereicht wird und viele haben auch gefragt, so was hat's denn irgendwie hiermit auf sich.
Ja und das ist irgendwie das ist echt so eine Sache. Also zunächst einmal seine Behauptung ist, er hätte einen Impfstoff äh entwickelt,
in den Berichten ist von einem Antikin äh
Impfstofftirede, also was das letztlich meint, ist ein proteinbasierter Impfstoff. Ich hatte ja hier letzte Woche auch mal so äh kurz nochmal so vorgestellt, in welche Kategorien die die Impfstoffe, die jetzt
quasi entweder schon verimpft werden oder Kandidaten für eine baldige Zulassung sind und da hatten wir grob unterschieden in diese MRNA Impfstoffe, Divektorimpfstoffe
Im Stoffe mit abgetöteten.
Viren, wie sie zum Beispiel in China verfolgt werden, die klassischen Impfstoffe eigentlich und aber auch äh.
Zum Beispiel die Firma Novawax erwähnt in USA, die eben jetzt demnächst mit einem Proteinimpfstoff an Start kommt.
Was es eigentlich bedeutet ist, dass man eben hier nicht einen Virus oder eben im Falle der RNA-Impfstoffe
R und A Element in den Körper einbringt, was,
auf dem einen oder anderen Wege den Körper dazu bringt selber dieses Bike Proteine zu erzeugen, woraufhin dann der Körper mit der Immunreaktion äh antworten kann, sondern dass man eben,
dieses Protein selbst herstellt, also dass man quasi direkt dieses Bike-Protein erzeugt und dann eben durch die Impfung in den Körper bringt und dann
eben den Körper dazu bringen möchte, dagegen äh vorzugehen.
Also statt die körpereigenen Zellen ähm
die Proteine produzieren zu lassen, die bei den Vektor und MRNA-Impfstoffen nimmt man Bakterien, Kulturen, die im Grunde genommen dasselbe machen
filtert dann die entsprechenden Proteine raus und spritzt die dann direkt mit, dann aber eben wahrscheinlich Adjuvanci, nehme ich an, also mit Wirkverstärkern.
Genau, das ist nämlich dann so Teil äh der Geschichte. Hier muss man dann eben mit diesen Atjovancen arbeiten, welche dann in dem Moment zum Einsatz kommen und welche Wirkungen die dann wiederum auf den Körper haben. Das muss natürlich dann auch getestet werden.
Und also ist jetzt mitnichten so,
dass jetzt hier dieser Winfried Stöcker irgendwie ein ein Wundermittel irgendwie auf einmal aufgebracht hat, weil er
spricht natürlich dann Interviews und auch in diesem Spiegel TV
Video dann äh davon so, ja, das ist ja irgendwie viel besser als die ganzen anderen Impfstoffe und das ist irgendwie total äh die größte Erfindung
geschminkten Brot und damit könnte man ja innerhalb kürzester Zeit riesige Mengen erzeugen, so nach dem Motto die Pandemie wäre eigentlich schon längst vorbei, wenn man irgendwie Nummer auf mich gehört hätte
Mir ist nicht so hundertprozentig klar, welche Wege der jetzt eigentlich beschritten hat oder nicht, ne? Muss auch sagen, er hat da seine Firma verkauft und dann von der Kohle sich irgendwie nochmal so ein eigenes Labor aufgesetzt und da ähm betreibt er das halt irgendwie auch
in Lübeck und der eigentliche Aufreger ist, dass als dann äh die ähm.
Zuständigen Behörden, also das äh paar Ehrliche Institut äh Wind bekommen hat von seinen Experimenten, denn äh Ermittlungen
Also wurde sozusagen Anzeige gegen ihn erstattet und es laufen sozusagen jetzt äh Ermittlungen, ob er dann sozusagen hier an dieser Stelle äh illegale Menschen versuche.
Gestartet hat. Und das war dann so ein bisschen auch der Aufreger in diesen Berichten so nach dem Motto ja jetzt haben wir hier irgendwie ein.
Menschen, der einen tollen Impfstoff hat und das System wendet sich gegen ihn und anstatt das zu unterstützen,
wird jetzt hier irgendwie gegen ihn ermittelt. Das ist so ein bisschen so dieses Bild was ich in diesem Bericht abgezeichnet hat.
Also es ist ein bisschen schwierig das zu bewerten, ne? Aber man muss jetzt erstmal sagen, also das, was da sozusagen behauptet wird, was er entwickelt hat.
Ist jetzt so an sich nicht was Neues, sondern Proteinimpfstiffe sind sozusagen auch auf der Liste bei anderen Herstellern. Die Entwicklung solcher äh Impfstoffe ist,
relativ langwierig, weil eben diese Herstellung, dieser Proteine
dieser sogenannten Rekombinanten äh Proteine, die also dann das Immunsystem anregen ähm ist erstmal nicht so trivial, so die Einschätzung, die ich bekommen habe,
Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so nur, weil man jetzt so mal ein paar davon hergestellt hat, dass man das mal soeben auf eine große Menge skalieren kann
und kommt eben auch noch hinzu, müssen auch noch äh Verstärker hinzugegeben werden, also damit das sozusagen funktioniert. Sprich, da passiert dann was mit dem Körper und das ist halt etwas, das muss eben dann auch
entsprechend in groß aufgestellten Phase eins, zwei, drei, Tests durchgeführt werden und das hat halt bei ihm jetzt mitnichten
ist das passiert, was er gemacht hat ist, er hat irgendwie seine Familie und offensichtlich auch einige seiner Mitarbeiter damit geimpft und behauptet halt jetzt so in diesen äh Berichten so, die werden jetzt halt alle Immun.
Ja und das hätte ja auch Herr Drosten bestätigt, ja? Äh klar, er hat halt irgendwie dem Drosten irgendwelche äh Proben geschickt von von seinem eigenen Blutplasma, also er hat sich,
zu sagen selbst geimpft und dann wurden wohl auch Antikörper aufgebaut und das dient wohl auch durchaus gegen zumindest ich weiß jetzt nicht zu welchem Zeitpunkt das stattgefunden hat, zumindest gegen die zu dem Zeitpunkt,
im äh Umlauf befindlichen Viren
gab's da durchaus eine Wirkung, aber das heißt halt noch lange nicht, dass eben jetzt dieser Impfstoff als solcher gut verträglich ist, auch wirklich funktioniert, groß skaliert äh hergestellt werden kann, et cetera PP.
Ja. Ich glaube auch ein Problem ist äh generell,
auch wenn du halt jetzt da deine äh deine Zählkultur ansetzt, um äh dann mit Hilfe von Zellen oder Enzymen äh dann die Proteine äh.
Zu produzieren, kommen dabei halt nicht nur die Proteine raus,
die du gerne hättest, sondern halt jede Menge anderes Zeugs, was du halt in dem Impfstoff nicht drin haben willst und deswegen
ist halt immer das A und O auch bei der Impfstoffherstellung das zu halt diese ganzen unerwünschten,
Stoffe äh rausfilterst und äh das ist halt dann auch nicht so einfach, weil
du das natürlich dann ja großtechnisch machen musst, aber das ja.
Denke äh dass das geht und wahrscheinlich ja funktioniert seinen Impfstoff auch aber
ja es gibt keinen Grund jetzt irgendwie anzunehmen dass der irgendwie besser ist oder wie gesagt auch wirksam ist. Ich meine das ist halt ja also mit,
mit vier oder fünf Leuten, die dann Antikörper äh produzieren. Hm, das ist nicht der Standard.
Nachdem man irgendwie Impfstoffe testet oder oder zulässt und äh ja.
Ja, also der Mensch ist auch durchaus äh also ich kannte den irgendwie vorher nicht, ne? Wenn du wenn man jetzt mal in der Wikipedia äh nachschlägt, da sind halt so einige Berichte zusammengetragen.
Äh scheint schon seit längerer Zeit so in Lübeck auch so sich so ein bisschen zu so einer Person anongrather zu äh entwickeln auf jeden Fall hat die
äh da irgendwie jede Kooperation mit ihm irgendwie eingestellt, das hat wohl auch damit zu tun, dass er äh schon vor vielen Jahren und dann auch in der Flüchtlingskrise
sehr unangenehm aufgefallen ist, weil er dann irgendwie auch so zu den Leuten gehörte, die dann irgendwie gegen die äh Flüchtlinge einiges vorzubringen hatten. Die hätten ja irgendwie kein Recht, sich hier in Deutschland festzusetzen und war dann irgendwie auch ganz vorne dabei und hat vor der Islamisierung Deutschlands
gewarnt, ähm dann haben sich halt so schon Parteien, Kirchen und auch die Universität in Lübeck so äh von ihm,
distanziert und äh äh ist dann also auch in der äh Folge nicht nicht weniger laut äh geworden.
Ja es es war wahrscheinlich er ist es so wie ich gelesen habe äh
sozusagen noch ein noch ein Schritt weiter gegangen als nicht nur zu sagen, die haben kein Recht, sich hier festzusetzen, sondern er hat das sozusagen auch damit begründet, dass das halt, ich sage mal, minderwertige Menschen sind, die hierher kommen,
So und äh ja ähm also auf der anderen Seite.
Alles natürlich jetzt nichts mit äh seinem Impfstoff zu tun, ob der gut ist oder oder schlecht, aber in der Tat äh ist es äh glaube ich
erklärt es auch äh warum jetzt das Ganze nicht so begeistert.
Aufgenommen wurde, äh was er da getan hat und.
Also es gibt da eine Zurückhaltung ihm gegenüber, ne? So, weil,
mehrfach sehr negativ aufgefallen ist und wie die in seinem Blog irgendwie zum Sturz der Kanzlerin Merkel aufgerufen hat und was nicht alles. Also mir erscheint.
So ein bisschen auch aus diesem Bericht, den ich gesehen habe, wenn man hier so reden äh hört doch ein sehr von sich selbst überzeugter Mensch zu sein
der hier gerne mal mit äh Thesen voranschießt und Behauptungen äh
wie toll denn jetzt sein Impfstoff doch so wäre, aber auf der anderen Seite offenbar
nicht bereit ist äh das auf einen normalen Weg zu bringen, beziehungsweise einfach auch nicht in der Lage ist, hier die entsprechenden Partner dafür zu finden. Weil ich meine, nichts hätte ja
daran gehindert, hier irgendwie eine Partnerschaft mit 'nem Pharmaunternehmen einzugehen und zu sagen, so hier super, ich hab hier 'n supergeilen Protein im Stoff entwickelt, könnt ihr das mal bitte fördern und könnt ihr vor allem mal die notwendigen
Phase eins, zwei, drei, Studien hier auch vorzunehmen. Stattdessen hat er sozusagen in Eigenregie,
da in im kleinen Kreis irgendwie Impfungen veranlasst und das Ganze damit gerechtfertigt, der wäre ja irgendwie Arzt und er dürfte ja zur Heilung von Menschen alle notwendigen Maßnahmen ergreifen und das hätte schon irgendwie alles so sein sind, aber ich glaube
soweit ich die Regelung verstehe, ähm kann man das auch anders sehen. Kurz gesagt, man sollte hier, glaube ich.
Nicht in diesen Chor einstimmen und sagen, hier haben wir den totalen äh super äh Wunderheiler am Start, der hier irgendwie ein,
Impfstoff entwickelt hat und äh der Staat das System oder was auch immer hat nichts besseres zu tun, als ihn irgendwie daran zu hindern,
waren bei genauerem Hinschauen ähm
ist glaube ich eine gewisse Zurückhaltung, was eine Person betrifft, durchaus angemessen auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite äh ist es jetzt auch nicht so, dass das, was er da entwickelt hat irgendwie eine totale Revolution der Medizin darstellt.
So kann man das glaube ich mal zusammenfassen. Und wer Bock auf Proteindippstoffe hat, gibt's dann demnächst von von Nova Wachs.
So
Ja, sind wir eigentlich durch mit den Themen für heute, oder? So, dann sagt vielleicht.
Abschließenden Ausblick.
Also ähm ja, wie gesagt, hier geht's jetzt weiter ähm.
Ich meine, je nachdem wie.
Sehr äh sich die Kontakte jetzt erhöhen. Ähm also wir werden ziemlich sicher äh.
Über hundert kommen in diesem Monat bei den Institzen, also Ende des Monats werden wir ähm ja.
Selbst wenn jetzt ähm die Kontakte nicht weiter zunehmen mh.
Sagt bei hundert landen äh nehmen die Kontakte um zwanzig Prozent zu, wie
dass eigentlich eine realistische Erwartung ist, äh dann wird meine im Moment.
Etwas verwiegen, aussehende Zweihunderter äh Prognose für Ende April äh könnte halt doch noch eintreffen, so.
Meine es könnte schlimmer sein, schlimmer geht immer. Wir haben jetzt
immerhin so diese diese Grenze mit den hundert, aber
das ist halt auch wieder wie wir gesehen haben ja nur so eine halbe Grenze, das heißt wenn dann die hundert überschritten werden, dann werden dann wieder Lockerungen zurückgenommen
ähm ob das dann auch.
Bei der Bevölkerung so zu dem Bewusstsein führt selber die Kontakte zu reduzieren. Ähm! Es ist ja immer so, hat mir auch das sagen,
die Leute auch auf Institzwerte sehr wohl reagieren und auf die Nachrichtenlage so, das heißt,
in dem Moment, wo die wo viele Leute sehen, okay, äh die Zahlen sind hoch, passen die halt einfach mehr auf, unabhängig davon, ob jetzt verschärft wird oder nicht, aber einen,
Teil nutzt halt auch alles aus, äh, was geht und ein anderer Teil sogar, dem ist es halt
egal der setzt sich halt auch mehr oder weniger über die Maßnahmen äh hinweg
und macht einfach nichts hält sich nicht dran und ja ähm im Moment.
Sieht es so aus, ja. Ähm also im besten Fall werden wir die hundert,
äh überschreiten und wahrscheinlich äh werden wir aber äh schon äh in Richtung zweihundert äh marschieren äh auf denke mal.
Im Mai beziehungsweise das hält dann hängt dann davon ab,
was halt passiert, sobald wir die hundert äh überschritten haben und wie schnell wir die hundert überschreiten und äh davon wird es halt, glaube ich, auch abhängig sein. Mh,
wie groß die nächste Welle werden wird und.
Aus anderen Ländern ist die Erfahrung, dass äh die wahrscheinlich höher werden wird, aber dann nicht so lange dauert und schneller runter gehen wird, weil.
Ja dann wieder Panik ausbricht irgendwann und mehr Panik ausbricht, weil die Institutionen dann höher sind.
Also wir haben jetzt noch sozusagen mehr Panik äh am Horizont.
Ja, also erstmal haben wir jetzt sagen erstmal können wir uns jetzt
die nächsten Wochen über ein paar Lockerungen freuen so ein, zwei, drei Wochen lang und äh ja dann äh wird's wahrscheinlich wieder,
Schluss mit lustig werden. So sieht's aus und ja also.
Ähm ich fürchte ja am meisten fast so ein Szenario wie in den letzten Monaten, dass das alles dann wieder so mit mit halben Maßnahmen und Schulen bleiben offen und dann äh,
kämpfen wir uns da wahrscheinlich wieder ewig bei irgendwelchen viel zu hohen Institutionen ab und ja.
Ja, vor allem denke ich, dass eben einfach der zunehmende Erfolg der Impfung äh dann immer diese diesen Grund liefern wird so, na was wollt ihr denn? Die alten sterben ja jetzt nicht mehr, weil die ja alle geimpft.
Ja, aber da hatten wir vorher schon gezeigt, dass solange nicht das Impftempo drastisch erhöht wird, werden wir bis August noch äh.
So viele wolenerable Personen haben, dass wir pro Millionen.
Infizierte, dann äh ja mit.
Zigtausend Toten rechnen können, vielleicht nicht mit den dreißigtausend pro Millionen, die wir hatten oder den sechzigtausend aus der letzten Welle hoffentlich aber.
Es wird leider signifikant werden und wahrscheinlich äh.
Werden die neuen Ansteckungen dann auch irgendwie äh nochmal die Millionen erreichen oder,
vielleicht sogar mehrere Millionen bis wir damit durch sind und wie vorhin geschildert äh schlägt halt jede einzelne Infektion im Schnitt mit,
mehreren tausend Euro zugrunde, also je nachdem wie man rechnet äh kostet uns eine Infektion drei bis fünftausend Euro,
Ähm ja und da kommen halt dann pro Millionen dann eben drei bis fünf Milliarden zusammen.
Die uns der Spaß kostet durch Behandlungskosten, durch Arbeitsausfall eines Teils äh der Leute und andere Dinge.
Ja und dann, wie gesagt, nochmal der,
Hinweis auf Longkovic, da gibt's halt auch sehr schöne Statistiken mittlerweile und wir wissen, dass ein Viertel der Infizierten nach fünf Wochen noch mindestens ein Symptom,
hat. Das sind zumindest die.
Zahlen aus England und das kann natürlich noch sich beliebig lange fortsetzen.
Und das will man halt auch nicht. Also man will's einfach.
Nicht haben. So und bei den Leuten halt manifestiert es sich wie so eine.
Wenn man Grippe, die einfach nicht weggehen will. So,
hatte, vielleicht hat vielleicht jeder auch schon mal erlebt, äh mal so eine hartnäckige Erkältung, äh wo man das Gefühl hat, irgendwie, das geht und geht und geht nicht weg und so fühlt sich das dann bei vielen äh.
An mit Lonkowitt, dass der Husten bleibt oft oder das Müdigkeit bleibt oder.
Konzentrationsschwächen habe ich auch oft gehört.
Und äh.
Ja insofern denke ich ähm wir sollten,
Infektionen einfach vermeiden und eigentlich ich meine, wenn jetzt sagen dieser dieser kleine Öffnungsreigen, äh der da jetzt stattfindet äh schon
jetzt unvermeidbar ist, ist meine Hoffnung zumindestens, wenn,
sich davon, wenn sich die Folgen bemerkbar machen, wozu das führt, dass wir dann wenigstens schnell und konsequent reagieren beim.
Zweiten Welle, wo wir erstmal eineinhalb Monate gewartet haben,
Mhm.
Um und dann äh nur inkonsequent halbherzig gehandelt haben. Ich hoffe ja, dass wir das nicht nochmal wiederholen werden, aber die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Auf jeden Fall müssen wir äh glaube ich äh dran arbeiten, dass äh unser Zahlenmaterial wieder äh auftaucht.
Vielleicht magst du ja nochmal am Schluss ähm für die technische äh Community nochmal eine kurze Ansage machen. Wir hatten da ja schon mehrfach
drüber gesprochen, dass ja eigentlich mal ganz schön wäre, diesen ganzen Datenkram einerseits ein bisschen feiner aufzudröseln und vielleicht auch nochmal ein paar etwas sinnvollere ähm Visualisierung dazu zu bekommen
paar Leute hatten sich auch schon freundlicherweise äh gemeldet, mit dem wir auch schon ähm regelmäßig im Gespräch sind, aber die Sache stellt sich ja äh etwas komplex dar, vielleicht kannst du ja mal nochmal ausführen, wie du dir die Zukunft dieser Risikotabelle äh
gedacht hast.
Gut, also diese Risikotabelle basiert halt.
Auf den NPGO Datendampf des LKI, die halt.
Täglich, ja, veröffentlicht werden, so irgendwann zwei, drei Uhr nachts äh steht
das dann online. Da kann man das dann Prinzip runterladen und abrufen und das ist immer eine.
Plötte Sammlung aller Fälle seit Beginn der Pandimie. Sozusagen jeden Tag wird diese Datei ein bisschen größer.
Und enthält und enthält alles. So, außer was sie nicht enthält, ist.
Wann denn eine bestimmte Infektion jetzt gezählt wurde, also wann sie an welchem Tag sie in die offiziell veröffentlichte Statistik,
eingegangen ist. Das heißt, ich habe zwar, wenn ich ein Datendamp runterlade, habe ich zwar sagen.
Alle jemals stattgefundenen Fälle und Sterbefälle und so.
Nur ich kann daraus nicht die offizielle Zahlenreihe rekonstruieren, also wenn ich mir jeden Tag wird ja eine Zahl an Neuinfektionen
veröffentlicht und das ist dann die die Zahlenreihe und an an Sterbefällen.
Also es fehlt eigentlich ein Feld, wo drin steht, seit wann gibt es diesen Datensatz.
Genau, es fehlt ein.
Fällt sagen seit wann ist dieser Fall oder an welchem Tag wurde dieser Fall veröffentlicht so? Wenn es das gäbe bräuchte man,
diesen ganzen, diesen ganzen Aufwand äh nicht und äh wenn man auch auf die zum Beispiel auf die offiziellen NPG-Seiten, also auf dieses Corona-Dashboard, diese Karte vom RKI geht
und.
Klickt dort auf einzelne Landkreise oder auf auf Bundesländer oder so äh sieht man halt dann auch Verläufe.
So Infektionsverläufe, aber die entsprechen eben nicht den.
Gemeldeten Zahlen, sondern das sind dann halt, da kann ich mir dann entweder nach Meldedatum oder nach Infektionsdatum, aber nicht nach Veröffentlichungsdatum und da.
Ist das Problem, wenn ich die nach Meldedatum oder nach Infektionsdatum nehme, dann habe ich aufgrund de
Übermittlungsverzugs am Ende der Kurve immer eine auf null abfallende Kurve, das heißt, ich kann,
diesen äh Kurven,
den aktuellen Trend gar nicht erkennen, ja? Ohne irgendwie dann eine Now-Cast äh zu veranstalten. So, deswegen möchte man auch in der Lage sein, rauszufinden,
wann äh denn eine bestimmte Zahl veröffentlicht wurde, beziehungsweise die offiziellen eben Zahlenreihen hm mit dem Veröffentlichungsdatum auch rekonstruieren und an und anzeigen äh zu können. Dazu.
Muss man dann aber äh sämtliche Datendamps.
Von Anfang an vorhalten. Leider gehen die Datendamps auch nicht bis an den Anfang der Pandimie zurück. Das ist halt auch noch ein,
Problem, dass man halt dann die ersten Wochen nicht mit drin hat, also die halbe erste Welle fehlt eigentlich äh in den in den Datendamps, das
lässt sich jetzt nicht nicht ändern. Äh da gibt's halt nicht mehr. Das System war halt glaube ich vorher nicht online. Ähm.
So und um also auf die.
Korrekten Zahlen zu kommen, muss man eben diese Datendamps, das sind so ja,
paar hundert Megabyte für jeden Tag, also am Anfang noch wenig. Im Moment sind's so fünfhundert Megabyte, muss man halt
alle vorhalten. Also die insgesamt die gesamten Datendamps äh sind jetzt äh ungefähr vierzig Gigabyte groß.
Und jeden Tag kommt ein halbes Gigabyte dazu.
Genau und jeden Tag kommt ein halbes Gigabyte dazu
Und wenn ich halt die offiziellen Zahlen reinrechnen will, muss ich mir halt äh diese äh gesamten vierzig Gigabyte äh halt durcharbeiten
und zwar ähm ja Tausende von Malen muss ich da Auswertungen drüber fahren so und.
Das habe ich jetzt soweit auch sagen am am Start,
das Ganze, das das gibt es, also ich kann jetzt die offiziellen Daten rein rekonstruieren und nicht nur das. Ähm.
Ich,
schreibe halt bereits Daten rein, äh jeweils für hm die verschiedenen Altersstufen und für die Geschlechter und so, so dass ich dann am Ende mit.
Einer Datei sage ich mal oder einem einer Tabelle,
Für jeden Landkreis und eine für jedes Bundesland und eine äh für Deutschland gesamt äh komme
die dann halt alle möglichen Spalten enthalten eben für
Neuinfektion für Infektion komuliert, für Tote, für Tote komuliert und dann eben für Infektionen in der Altersgruppe und auch Genesung in der Altersgruppe und ja.
Das äh ist sozusagen jetzt gerade der der Stand, den ich, den ich habe mit der,
neuen Pipeline und was ich im Moment mache, ist, ich lade mir die Daten ins Excel
und mache dann im Moment mit Excel die eine oder andere Visualisierung zum Beispiel für Berlin äh was wir halt vorhin erwähnt hatten, so dies nach Alters äh Gruppen ähm oder.
Institutionen nach Altersgruppen, so dass es stammt aus diesen neuen,
Tabellen, die daneben in Excel äh visualisiert wurden. Ja ähm was ich jetzt gerade.
In den letzten Tagen dazu gebaut habe ist was mir noch fehlte um sagen nicht nur.
Zahlen der infizierten zu haben oder die Zahlen der Toten, sondern die tatsächlichen Institenzen.
Pro Altersgruppe und nicht nur die Zahlen pro Altersgruppe muss ich natürlich wissen wie viele Menschen,
in dieser Altersgruppe jetzt in diesem Landkreis oder Land wohnen. Das ist natürlich eine
krasse Datenbasis, aber wir haben ja Volkszählungen in Deutschland und wir haben eben auch Zensusdaten, Banken und da kann man dann auch genau diese Daten runterladen, aber
nicht genau in den
Altersstufen, wie sie zu den RKI-Datensätzen passen, weil da gibt's halt diese Altersstufen null bis vier. Äh dann fünf bis.
Vierzehn und fünfzehn bis fünfunddreißig und dann fünfunddreißig bis und so weiter und achtzig plus und so nur und da gibt es aber äh dann kein,
Angebot,
genau diese Zahlen, in denen Altersgruppen runterzahlen, aber man kann dann den Weg gehen und,
sich die Zahlen für jedes einzelne Jahr holen,
und dann die entsprechenden Jahre, die man dann braucht, um auf das RKI-Format zu kommen, dann zusammenzählen, ist halt auch ja.
Nicht ganz unproabarist, das das geht, das hat das habe ich halt dann auch gemacht. Weiteres Problem war aber noch, dass in den Bundesdaten,
nicht die Daten für die Berliner Bezirke mit enthalten sind, die mich natürlich auch besonders
interessieren so, da gibt es eben aus den letzten in den letzten Volkszählungsdaten halt nichts drüber, die gibt's dann aber wiederum bei Statistik Berlin Brandenburg, allerdings nur von zweitausenddreizehn
So, weißt, dann habe ich mir dort noch die zweitausenddreizehner Daten äh besorgt, weil das die neuesten sind für die Bezirke
Aber die passen dann natürlich nicht zu den neueren Volkszählungsdaten. Die sind natürlich dann viel zu niedrig. Und deswegen habe ich dann noch
Also ich hatte halt die wiederum die Daten für ganz Berlin aktuell
und dann habe ich einfach noch die Daten für die Bezirke in den einzelnen Altersgruppen entsprechend hochgerechnet.
Auf die neueste Volkszählung, damit halt die Summen der einzelnen Bezirke, auch die Summen der aktuellen Volkszählung für Berlin ergeben. So.
Ja. So, jetzt habe ich halt äh tatsächlich äh ähm.
Für sämtliche Bezirke und Länder und auch für die Berliner,
Bezirke halt 'ne schöne Datenbasis wo ich weiß wie viele Menschen in dieser entsprechenden jetzt passenden Altersgruppe dort.
Ähm wohnen, sodass ich dann tatsächlich mit richtigen Institzen pro hunderttausend Einwohnern dann rechnen kann.
Zu.
Diese Datenbasis jetzt zu zu produzieren äh ist halt der nächste Schritt. Da muss ich noch ein paar Stunden aufwenden, um dann auch äh,
haben überall die Inzidenzspalten jetzt noch einzurechnen. Problem ist so ein Lauf äh dauert
auf meinem Laptop dann jetzt
mehrere Stunden auf jeden Fall und wenn jetzt also es wird zu sechs bis acht Stunden dauern, das heißt, da muss ich dann halt auch noch was machen, beziehungsweise,
da ist dann der Plan, dass halt jeweils nur für den neusten Tag zu machen und eben nicht die gesamten Tabellen neu rauszurechnen und ja an der Stelle
käme dann auch möglicherweise eine Datenbank ins Spiel, in die man dann jeweils jeden Tag für.
Jeden Landkreis und jedes Land eine neue.
Zeile äh in die in die Tabelle hängt, also wo man dann pro Tag äh ja äh fallen dann ungefähr fünfhundert.
Äh an äh neuen Daten an äh wobei das dann, weiß ich nicht, hundert, zweihundert Spalten sind äh oder so, aber es ist alles dann eine handhabbare Datenmenge pro Tag. So,
Und dann möchte ich im nächsten Schritt äh sobald ich das habe, dann erstmal die Tabelle, also
was ich jetzt äh nach dem diesen Konsolidierungsverfahren, was aber jetzt aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist, äh möchte ich gerne die Risikotabelle.
Wieder äh daraus generieren, aber vor allem sind natürlich dann diese Daten äh wunderbar geeignet,
um ganz tolle Kurven zu machen. Äh also ganz tolle Grafiken, äh wo man dann hm,
ja für jeden im Prinzip, für jeden Landkreis sehen kann, äh, wie sich dort die Institanz in welchen Altersgruppen.
Entwickelt hat und ähm äh andere Dinge eventuell wäre dann auch noch interessant. Äh.
Einen Feature, äh wo man dann tatsächlich.
Ein Tag reingehen kann und sich dann die Fälle eines Tages nochmal genauer angucken kann,
Das ist aber auch eher erstmal erstmal ein bisschen perspektivisch,
und ähm ja ansonsten,
habe ich halt auch noch die Geodaten, das heißt, es steht auch nichts im Wege, dann das Ganze auch als Karte äh zu visualisieren. Es gibt auch,
die Schwerpunkte jedes
Landkreises, so dass man dann auch Auswertungen machen kann über ja, nachbarschaftliche Beziehungen, wie ist das, wie ist es da gelaufen, Plus
Ich habe auch die Fläche äh von jedem.
Landkreis mittlerweile drin, so dass man dann auch Institzen pro Fläche äh oder so angeben äh.
Kann. Also viele neue Möglichkeiten ähm aber jetzt nachdem halt leider sagt die alte Tabelle so falsche Zahlen auswirft, steht halt erstmal im Vordergrund,
wie möglichst viele Features von der Tabelle zu rekonstruieren.
Das erstmal zu reparieren, um dann weiter.
Parieren. Genau. Ja.
Was die Visualisierung angeht, also die Pläne sind dann zum einen durch diese Datenbasis dann bereitzustellen, dass jeder dann auch da selber seine Visualisierung mit.
Machen kann, weil das ist mit den äh mit dieser Datenbasis dann halt einfach super einfach ganz super einfach mit Excel hingehen und für deinen Landkreis, wenn du willst, was machen, aber eigentlich ist eben der Plan
dann auch,
Mhm. Und sagen, für jeden Landkreis zumindest diese Visualisierung in der Art, wie ich sie für ganz Deutschland mache, somit Institzverlauf und
erwert und Verlauf, wie viele,
Menschen gestorben äh sind und andere Dinge, dass halt jeweils in eine Grafik äh zu packen und die dann auch schon mal fertig zu produzieren oder äh alternativ
halt mit irgendeinem einem Framework äh daraus dann interaktive Grafiken zu produzieren, die dann vom Java Skript im Browser erzeugt werden, so äh ja,
wie das dann auch mit Dash der Fall ist. Und auch so technisch äh habe ich das Ganze bisher in Peißen realisiert. Ich habe auch diesen.
Super Quick and Dirty Code äh ist, befindet sich auch auf Gitarb. Ähm es ist allerdings im Moment eine Zumutung
auch äh ja sich damit zu beschäftigen, aber ich habe ihn trotzdem rausgehauen, weil es gib.
Keine Dokumentation dazu oder wie man das Ding verwendet, aber wer neugierig ist, kann da halt dann dann trotzdem
äh mal einen Blick reinwerfen und ja äh.
Wer ich meine ich bin eigentlich eher Technologie agnostisch, aber äh ich,
ja ich hab jetzt nur mal den den Weg über Peißen, so das Schweizer Taschenmesser ähm.
Andere Leute machen's gerne auch mit Notes, JavaSkript, ja.
Kann man auch tun, ist auch ein großes, großes Universum
Schauen wir mal. Also ich ich werd's auf jeden Fall jetzt voran äh treiben und gucken, wer dann äh Lust hat, äh sich sich.
Ja zu zu beteiligen oder Dinge damit zu machen, kann sich halt halt auch gerne bei mir.
Melden
ähm oder auch in den am besten in den in den Kommentaren äh irgendwie eine Möglichkeit hinterlassen, äh wie ich die Leute kontaktieren kann. Ich bitte dann aber um Verständnis, äh wenn das vielleicht dann doch
etwas länger dauert, weil ich will erstmal die Sachen, die jetzt noch,
gerade offen habe, erstmal fertig machen und dafür sorgen, dass die Tabelle wieder.
Richtige Dinge anzeigt und dann würde ich an dem Punkt äh dann äh ja durchaus auch gerne.
Vielleicht sogar ein ein Projekt starten. Hm und.
Ich habe einen Server äh mehrere Server draußen, die leistungsfähig genug sind, dass man das dann auch dort laufen lassen kann, weil das andere Problem ist. Mhm
bei größeren Mengen ähm,
Hosting oder größeren Rechenaufwand, also vierzig Gigabyte oder so zum Download auch anzubieten
wenn du das auf Amazon machst oder anderen Dingen oder Githab oder so dann geht das halt super krass,
ins Geld. So und äh ja deshalb halt ähm.
Ja, aber da habe ich, habe ich halt eine eigene Infrastruktur, hm.
Wo ich im Übrigen dann auch noch, falls jemand dann Lust äh hat, äh dort auch ein bisschen.
Mitzuhelfen, dann dort ein System aufzubauen, was.
Bisschen Virtualisierung einsetzt und Monitoring und äh den den ganzen Kram, den man halt so
so braucht und ähm ja äh hinreichend zugenagelt ist, dass dass keiner aufhakt und ähm ich habe
da schon einen Freiwilligen, der unter der Bedingung mitmacht, dass sich noch ein anderer Freiwilliger findet äh.
Also und dann äh wie gesagt, wo ich auf jeden Fall äh äh durchaus äh dann auch Hilfe äh äh gebrauchen kann, ist dann bei dem,
ganzen äh Web.
End fürs Webfrontend. Äh so oder wie auch immer man das nennen will und äh ja.
Genau, also ihr könnt euch melden alles unter dem Vorbehalt, dass jetzt erstmal noch sehr viel technische Vorarbeit äh erforderlich ist, aber
wir sind da durchaus offen für Angebote für Leute, die zu viel Zeit haben oder dass irgen,
zumindest als eine ausreichend ähm interessante Tätigkeit äh ansehen, da so ein bisschen in den Daten äh rumzuforschen, wird noch ein bisschen brauchen. Äh es gibt ja auch die Mieterebene Community, also ich habe so ein Slack äh System laufen, wo Hörerinnen, Hörer von Mitterebene sich äh tummeln, da gibt's einen Kanal, der heißt Korona Wiegdi
da äh haben sich schon ein paar Leute eingefunden, die
da vielleicht mithelfen wollen und das ist sicherlich auch ein Ort, wo man irgendwie kurzfristig Fragen stellen kann und so ein bisschen schon mal abtasten kann, wie wie es denn so gerade so äh steht oder
Angebote einkippen, wie man vielleicht meint, äh künftig mithelfen zu können.
Was ich auch noch ganz gerne dann machen würde, äh so Dinge, die ich auch schon lange auf dem Schirm habe, dann äh zum Beispiel auch zu gucken, das wäre ein schönes Subprojekt,
Crowler zu machen oder einen eine Pipeline, die halt die aktuellen Wetterdaten für jeden Landkreis einspeist
um dann nochmal äh eine statistische Auswertung fahren zu können für alle Landkreise.
Denn irgendwie Wetter und Infektionszahlen irgendwie zusammenhängen, dass das wäre noch interessant, weil
wenn man halt das für hinreichend viele Kreise macht, kann man dort daneben auch äh raus
rechne mal gucken wo war denn das Wetter anders aber die Maßnahmen gleich oder alle anderen Umstände,
gleich und dann habe ich halt die Hoffnung, dass man da vielleicht ein bisschen bessere Werte für jetzt die Frage Saisonalität oder genauer sogar wetterabhängigkeit ähm äh.
Dass dass man das halt ähm ein bisschen besser untersuchen kann, dass wir Beispiel ein schönes Subprojekt,
andere Sache, die ich auch gelegentlich äh gemacht habe,
ist ähm lang Google Trendsbörse Zahlen aus Google Trends rauszuholen, also sprich Suchbegriffe, wann wurde wie häufig nach welchem Suchbegriff,
gesucht,
zum Beispiel nach Lockerung oder nach Lockdown oder nach Corona überhaupt oder so. Und da stellt man dann eben auch fest, äh dass es da auch
interessante Kurven äh gibt
und äh die halt dann mit der äh Infektionsentwicklung oder mit der R Entwicklung.
Zu korrigieren, also so ein bisschen, wenn man das Thema Nachrichtenlage äh auch numerisch,
zu erfassen, äh dass,
zum Beispiel auch so ein interessantes Subprojekt äh plus natürlich dann, wenn man das alles hat, äh kann man dann wieder.
In äh eine richtig geile äh Prognose machen, die nicht nur die Zahlen mit einbezieht, sondern auch die Nachrichtenlage mit einbezieht
äh so und äh ja, ich wüsste nicht, dass es irgendwas in der Richtung bereits gibt. Also äh ich denke ähm
ja, das könnte einfach Spaß machen, da was Neues äh
auf die Beine zu stellen, was auch dann nicht nur eine einmalige Studie ist, sondern was dann halt einfach auch läuft und und und weiterläuft und sozusagen jeden Tag daneben,
neue Daten und Prognosen und Erkenntnisse liefert. Ja, das ist die Vision. Schauen wir mal.
Okay, gut, super. Ich denke, äh damit belassen wir es dann auch mal bei dieser Sendung, die ist schon äh lang geworden.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank fürs Mitdenken, fürs Kommentieren, für eure Spenden auch, äh, um das Programm zu unterstützen. Wir hören uns dann nächste Woche wieder und bis dahin sagen wir tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüs.